A fuckers were alive before we even say
anything.
I have to do a favor for Ari.
Should fear are you should fears new
show his show brother.
This is not happening on comedy central
is starting a new season,
starting season two and r.
He really wants to get great stories
from comics that you guys all enjoy.
So what are you suggesting you do?
Is Perhaps tweet him,
uh,
suggestions and also tweet the comics
that you would like to see perform on
his show.
Basically everybody's got some fucking
wacky story.
Just one wacky story.
And if you've ever seen this is not
happening.
It's standups telling crazy stories
about either things that have happened
to them on the road or it during life or
what have you.
It's just a slightly different form of
standup.
So season two is about to begin.
And Ari would like you to just tweet at
anybody that you would think would be.
Don't harass anybody.
You don't twitter bond people.
That shit's gross.
People that asked me to twitter bomb,
Joe,
that's a great way to never get on this
podcast.
I,
it's annoying.
It's annoying as fuck.
I don't like it,
uh,
but this is not that.
What he wants you to do is just get the
word out about it and,
and tweet to him.
Anybody that you would like to see on it
that would,
that would help as well.
Right.
You fucks gentlemen.
Hey Man.
What's up brother?
That's funny you say that because like I
would see for like a year people go Joe
Abdeen on your podcast and I'm like,
that's the worst way to get me on.
Well,
not necessarily if you told them to do
it again would be the worst way.
We never did know.
You never would,
but a lot of people did suggested and I
watched you on to dom irrera a podcast
because of it,
which is fucking hilarious.
I've never seen donald rare life and the
laugh factory.
First of all,
dom's great guy.
Hilarious comic,
but it's a fun podcast and you were
really funny on that fucking show.
Oh thanks man.
Let's rock and roll stories.
God Damn Dude.
I mean you,
you fucking,
you came into comedy it through a really
weird way.
Yeah.
I came to fucking long way 25 years the
long way,
25 years of music played me as 25 years.
But the funny thing is,
uh,
when I was a kid I wanted to do comedy,
but there was no kids doing comedy,
you know,
it's not like now you can go to a camp
or you can just do whatever,
you know,
go to the comedy camp for kids.
That's how tiffany was started.
Laugh factory comedy camp as it like a
13 year old and same with Melissa in
your and uh,
but when I was a kid and I'm 49,
so I grew up on the first couple of
seasons of Saturday night live and I was
like,
I want to beat John Belushi.
GotTa be him.
But where can you be in?
Except for sixth grade?
Well,
there's open mics and stuff like that.
Like where'd you,
where'd you start out?
Where were you living when you were?
I
grew up in the bay area,
you know,
and uh,
San Francisco,
there was a mix,
but I'm like,
you know,
eighth grade,
you don't know about that.
There's no internet or anything.
Right.
And so you had already gotten into
music.
I started playing music and then the
years just flew by because the neighbors
piped music and,
and I love.
I loved rock and I love comedy.
And the seventies it was the same.
Yeah.
Cheech and Chong Carlin.
Richard Pryor said ACDC,
Ted Nugent,
van Halen.
They were just the same to me.
It put one record on and then the other.
Wow.
Yeah.
You.
So you lived next to musicians,
is that what got.
Well,
people in my neighborhood,
we all loved rock and they were like,
let's play.
Let's play in bands.
You know,
do you think of that wasn't around that
you would have gotten into stand up
early?
Well,
here's the thing.
Standup was huge in San Francisco in the
eighties,
man.
Yeah,
we had bobcat.
We had a bobby Slayton,
Robin Williams.
Uh,
we had the uh,
that morning show with Carrie snow and
all those guys,
you know,
it was huge,
but I just didn't know how to do it.
And I was probably scared.
I remember I saw dice and I was like,
I'm going to try comedy,
and I did one time at this bar,
mcnear's in Petaluma and I went in and I
was just trying to be like,
hey,
look at those tests and I swear it was
silent.
I was like,
fuck you,
and I thought this is how you do it.
Right?
And Man,
I was tossed out of there of course
intangible and you see a guy like dice
that can say like some of the most
offensive shit first of all because you
know him and you know,
like the character,
but there's also,
there's something about the way he did
it and like if you're a young kid and
you see it,
you think you could go do it too.
You don't realize how stupid it sounds
until it comes out of your mouth and you
realize like,
oh wait a minute.
He's been doing this for a long time.
Time.
Yeah,
it's established in about.
I saw dies in 88 at the store and she
really.
Well,
I used to hang at the store and my buddy
would like was dating the headway to
Sarah and and I'd probably rock and
Hollywood and then we'd go to the store
because it was huge.
Was that before or after?
He had become gigantic before.
Because I remember seeing him and then I
think like a year later he was on the
Rodney thing and that's like,
that's that guy I was telling you guys
about,
but he would do Monday nights and he
would go on and,
and all the rockers would go.
The rockers would be like,
you gotta see this guy man,
and you go down there and he'd come out.
He'd be like,
look at this whole,
hey,
be like,
what the fuck is this guy?
You're not getting beat up.
This guy was another guy laugh laughing.
He goes,
what are you left and that you're a
fucking asshole.
And that guy would get up and leave.
And then it was awesome,
man.
You know?
Yeah.
I call it mean dice.
Just two different dices.
There's dice,
there's mean dice and mean dice will
start picking on people in the audience
and fucking just lay into dudes for like
10,
15 minutes and you see,
they're like,
smile at
first.
I think I'll eventually get tired of
picking on me.
Move on to the next guy.
No,
I'm not done with you.
I'm not done with you yet.
Please be definitely.
What the fuck man came to see a comedy
show.
I didn't want to be a part of it.
Brutalize people,
radical but hilarious.
It was radical back then.
You know,
everybody's just flying around a coke
and his eighties and there's rock bands
and and great comedy going on.
That's what's different now.
That's a big thing that's different now
is coke.
The comedians are not on coke.
There's not a lot of comics on coke.
That's all we'd.
There's a few that drink,
but as far as like doing coke,
maybe a couple of them might do it,
but it's not like a Kennison thing were.
They're all just getting blasted like
you've heard Mark Marin's Kennison
stories.
Awesome.
The fucking,
the one about doing coke for like 78
hours and hallucinating for a year.
He was hearing voices for a fucking
year.
He had voices talking in his head for a
year after that.
That was the era man.
I mean,
I did coke every.
Not every day,
but like all of the time he just did
coke.
It was just what you did,
man.
It was rock coke and,
and you know.
And it wasn't about getting high.
It was just about.
Keep Rolling.
Let's keep this rolling.
Man.
Rock.
You don't want to quit?
No.
They want to go to bed.
Let's go bowling.
Then the liquor store will be open.
We'll hit that.
Then we'll go to this party and the
canyon.
Oh God.
That's great.
Open.
It's fun.
That's insane.
It's crossed out.
I worshiped sleep so much now.
I'm like,
I know when you're young you'll put that
sleep off.
Just like I could stay up.
I've done that many times.
Just stayed up and just figure it out.
Go to bed tonight.
You go to bed tonight.
Just ride it out.
And then the last few hours of your day,
you're just a Zombie.
Just were such bitches.
We need sleep.
We don't get that sleep.
You're like working at like 40 percent
capacity.
Like you have to struggle with
everything you do.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
Right?
Like I get angry when I don't get sleep,
man.
Fuck this crowd.
I remember being young though thinking
like just feeling like shit after
pulling an all nighter and thinking the
difference between me then and me now is
I'm probably more aware of how I feel
like shit now I'm more aware of what my
body actually requires.
When you're 20 years old and you do
something like that,
you don't think anything of it.
You just go.
One was taller.
Yeah.
The endurance is crazy.
When you're young,
you're just,
it's weird.
You can lay there and when you hear your
body working,
that's scary.
When it's just gone,
boom,
boom.
And you think about what you've made it
do.
It's just all booze and drugs in you and
you haven't eaten in a couple of days
that sprouts.
So how old were you when you got into
stand up?
A 44.
I've been doing it for five and a half
years.
Exactly last week.
Twenty 600 spots.
That's a fucking hustle dude.
It was weird.
Joe.
This is a true story.
When I started thinking of doing comedy,
all the guys though have during the
forties,
you know,
it's like you see K,
uh,
Tom,
papa was watching a lot burger and I
had,
I was really naive thinking like that.
It's not an age thing like rock,
you know,
Dr Rosa,
Rockstar.
There's only a few guys that get to that
Mick Jagger level where you can do
whatever the fuck you want
and they're looked at as like eno,
old rockers or whatever.
But comedians aren't looked at as old
comics.
They're looked at as comics because
they're,
the.
Most of the killers are in their
forties.
You know,
the guys I left.
Well,
there's,
there's something about your insight
when you get into your forties that is
probably missing when you're in your
thirties.
So can you throw that.
You can be really funny when you're in
your thirties,
but it's very rare that you find someone
in their thirties that has like the
insight of a Louis,
c,
k,
like the point of view,
the unique perspective of a burger.
You know?
It's like,
it takes a lot of living to become that
guy.
Yeah.
If you got it,
you have to travel or think.
Yeah,
you do.
You may have to come to their own.
You have to understand your own bullshit
too,
which a lot of times you don't yet when
you're in your thirties,
when you're in your thirties,
even if you're really funny,
you might have some funny points.
You probably don't understand your own
bullshit yet.
Yeah.
You got to admit to yourself and figure
it out.
I'm fucking shitty in some ways.
Yeah,
and then you talk about it on stage.
Did you
go to aa or one of those things where
you stand on a podium and make people
laugh?
That's how a lot of guys start.
Yeah,
and I didn't do that.
What happened was I drank and did coke
every night,
but I sang every night and had three
guys in my band.
I was losing my voice,
so I go to the doctor and he goes,
you can't drink alcohol.
It dries out your folk accords,
you've got like what they call pre
notes,
which is like calluses on your vocal
cords like Adele God or Steven Tyler or
as Paul Stanley,
and you got to go in and get them
lasered off.
You won't be able to sing for six months
and when the,
when you're making a living even two
days off,
even with comedy,
that completely makes the machine
crumble.
So my guys are like,
hey you,
you,
you can't drink.
You know,
we've got,
we've got to eat.
And I felt like that too.
I was like,
alright,
I gotta quit for a little bit and see
what happens.
Then after three weeks went by,
I felt fantastic and and I just never
looked back.
She never got it lasered?
No.
What I did was he told me two things.
Quit drinking.
Don't talk all day and don't talk after
gigs and I just chilled for like three
weeks and they slow and a lot of Ricole
was throat coat tea and uh,
and,
and the number one thing I did wrong,
which people don't know was when you
clear your throat,
it's the worst thing you can do when you
go to the banks and vocal chords
together.
And that's the worst thing you can do
for maybe just a bitch.
And I spoke with my vocal cords.
Don't mind rumbling a little bit.
Welcome cards,
lift weights to getting jacked,
running hills.
So you,
that was what made you quit drinking
like,
well,
I hadn't hit a rock bottom.
Cool.
I mean I was getting pretty radical.
I threw a beer and an anr guys face
that.
What's an a and r guy that's a radio
artist residence.
The guy that signs,
you know,
record labels.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So we're doing a showcase for what does
it stand for?
Artists and residents.
Representative
mentors are a represented artists were
relations,
customer relations.
You threw a beer in his face.
We're doing a showcase and there was a
bunch of record labels come down to see
us.
They're all hot and right before we go
on a,
they all start leaving our managers
like,
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
They were all leaving and so he calls
him the next day and they go,
well,
such and such said he signed you guys,
uh,
yesterday at lunch and so we left.
It was like a scam.
He did take and watch this on his own.
So I saw him about a month later I was
pretty drunk at an awards show and I
just had a beer and just right on his
face and topics and I was like,
yeah,
that's probably not good.
Good for the business.
Later though,
I seen him later and he's like,
that's pretty pretty gangster and really
gangster.
Yeah,
he knew it was like,
that's like the GNRH or rockers
crazy.
The fuck the guns and roses era.
Did you,
were you around for that?
Yeah.
Did you see them come up?
I saw him come up big time.
Yeah.
Uh,
I played in that whole scene,
you know,
like,
man,
that seems like one of the weirdest
errors of Hollywood because it seems
like a rock and roll era that nobody
really saw coming like a late eighties,
I mean outside of them.
And there was,
there's quite a few big bands from back
then,
but not necessarily big bands from La,
you know,
they were so much better than everybody
else.
You had them.
And Jane's addiction really,
those were the two and they played gigs
together and stuff.
When you think about the two styles are
totally different,
but they're both the uh,
the recipes are the same danger and
whenever you have something really
fucking dangerous,
it's gonna.
It's gonna hit with kids because you
know,
you're coming out of that Reagan era and
everything's kind of shitty and it's
like comedy was big in the eighties,
you know,
when it's bad,
people grab onto it and you had a long
time,
have a bad music,
you know,
you had a bunch of Super Glam spandex
stuff and then this thing comes in.
Welcome to the jungle and it feels real.
And the whole record is good.
That's why it made it.
It wasn't one,
two songs.
Yeah.
The record's fantastic.
But if you look at the original video
for welcome to the jungle,
he had t up here.
He's on the borderline of the Glam
thing.
Like somebody must've talked him into
dressing like that,
or he didn't know any better yet,
but he hair was like Farrah Fawcett
or something.
She's seen Dean's hair,
man.
It's just pictures that we could see
online on instagram page or anything
that we could find.
The Dean del Rey.
There's tons of pictures of me on there
from the old days they find me will find
it.
Well,
I want to see axl rose first.
Welcome to the jungle.
Yeah.
Because it changed.
Then it was black bandanas and greasy
hair and the heroin.
Look,
he went from the hairband look to the
heroin.
Look,
now you know,
I remember specifically seeing them.
This was the turning point.
They were grinding out and the record
came out.
You know that record failed when it
first came out.
People don't know the first single
bombed.
Really?
What was the first time?
The jungle,
that was the first bomb dudes like it,
but it wasn't,
you know,
it took.
We had to wait till you get the sweet.
Was there.
Look at that photo.
Photos.
Slightly grungy,
but you know what it is.
It's like you tried to be grunge there.
You worked it,
you know like that's your hair.
Doesn't stick up that watch.
No,
no.
That's hairspray.
She worked in a chemical plant.
You gotta think though,
man,
that is this era.
When you look at this,
and I always describe this to people and
you have tattoos.
I have tattoos in this era of the
eighties when you had tattoos,
that meant you were never working a
regular job at that time.
Now you look at Chipola,
you work at starbucks wherever,
but at that time that meant no one was
hiring.
You accept construction or landscaping.
You weren't going to get a job,
so that was a c.
I mean he has multiple giant tattoos to.
Yeah,
he just went out now
18 year old kids that have sleeves.
Exactly.
Side food boobs in fifth grade.
I always say I don't think I got enough
tattoos to work at Chipola yeah,
and ladies,
what's up with the.
The inspirational quotes below the side
boob.
So that is becoming.
That is the,
that is the fucking barbwire around the
bicep.
The 2015 errors,
the inspirational quote on your side
boots,
the new tramp stamp.
It's always like some fucking Ralph
Waldo emerson quote or or something
biblical.
It's never good.
Like a Charles Bukowski thing.
You know,
like I'm a day drinker.
He was,
he was another one.
That's one of my favorite
representations of Hollywood.
God
love you.
I know.
That's why I like,
like I like you.
I like guys that are dangerous and,
and I'm attracted to the edge.
A dislike.
Are you living on the edge?
It's funny.
Dean is now addicted to candy though.
I went over and crash cans full of candy
wrappers.
That's why I like listening to the ego
because it's like I'm trying to get
healthy
for real.
I quit caffeine.
I don't smoke.
I don't drink because I don't want to
die.
I worked seven nights a week,
man,
and I don't ever eat fast food ever,
but you can do.
It's bad.
Well,
Ari and I are trying to quit,
so we cut one day.
I've.
I'm up to two days now.
Sometimes three.
Yes.
Sugar can be really addictive.
You know why it's brutal because you've
been doing it since you were two.
You start drugs maybe when you're 18,
19,
but to your cereals,
loaded.
Your drinks are loaded.
Fucking breads loaded.
Fucking broad,
right?
The first day I quit smoking,
I eight,
six packs of Mentos and now I have the
hugest canker sores in my mouth so I can
tell from from just eating too much
candy and it hurts really bad.
I don't know if it's from that though.
It could be with you.
It can be like you.
What are you willing to analysts like?
You've observed all your illnesses.
Well,
I know this one,
this one came from Toronto.
You don't know where these sores are
coming from.
They just on your face so wrong.
So we're going to.
Toronto,
man will be there next month.
I love Toronto.
Me To write the dudes up there,
uh,
I did that room and they were talking
about you and they're like,
what's the epic night?
The comedy underground there.
And they had the punk club.
Yeah,
they had a picture of it in there and
stuff.
And they're like,
I've done it a few times.
It's so good.
That place is weird because it makes you
realize you can get a secondhand buzz
real easy.
I used to think that like secondhand,
like getting high second hand was
bullshit.
Not Enough fucking room.
No Way.
Go in that room.
You can't even see the back of the room
and the room is only 20 feet deep.
You can't see it.
It's the,
it's one of the few places that actually
made Doug Benson Green out where he
passed out in the middle of the lobby.
And then Tony,
Tony Hinchcliffe got off stage and he
took off his shirt and went outside and
almost fell down.
Oh my God.
I was headlining in there and I doing an
hour and smoke weed and my 30 minutes in
my throat was like someone shaved it
with sandpaper.
And then I was completely and I was up
there like this kinda cool man.
You know where I'm at?
Yeah.
They can hop box.
Any person in the world.
Just the air in there.
It's so thc filters.
No.
Really Aaron there.
None.
No.
It's all pots movement.
And now they're all doing that.
Um,
that uh,
dabbing.
So they're straight zombies.
That's correct.
I mean they are.
Zombies explained Dabbin.
What's the difference between dabbing
it?
Smoking weed.
They get this,
uh,
this is the wax,
like the oil light.
So I cash exactly.
But it's even stronger they say.
And then they've got this electrical
fucking wand and they kind of rub it
over it and then they suck in this,
this,
you know,
this like the word straight thc.
There's no weed.
How does the uh,
the,
the waiver of what over it?
It's pretty much exactly like smoking
crack foil.
But it's in a nice glass thing.
So you think it's not,
it's hash or anything like that?
Yes,
it's doing the exact same thing.
But when you start seeing this guy who,
uh,
was my,
what?
He wasn't in an agent,
he was my,
it wasn't my agent.
He was my manager's friend who was also
an agent.
He lit some Hash Hash on a,
like a,
um,
a thumbtack.
You put the piece of Hash on the
thumbtack and lit it on fire,
then put it under a glass.
Oh yeah.
And let it fill the glass up and they
lifted glass.
I'm going to go.
Great.
This guy is a drug addict.
Yeah.
That's all I could think of was this guy
was a drug addict.
Like if you just lit a joint,
like I was just,
I didn't,
I had no idea what the fuck.
So hey fuck hash was back then and look
at all the tools and the English,
they carry a briefcase with prosperous.
Like Ari and I were in Sacramento at the
punchline and this guy goes,
come out to the car.
He opened his trunk and he had like a,
a DAB center.
What is going on here?
So this guy's just hanging on there and
she's sort of working it while he,
uh,
turning and she's pretty much burning
it.
But Joe,
now they have state of the art things.
They're like electric wand and and,
and it rubs over it.
There's no fire.
It's like electric.
This is why potheads have a bad name.
Exactly.
Total.
He's guys waiting in line to get their
brains obliterated.
I think I told you this,
Joe,
that I recently was in San Francisco and
there was one of these places across the
street from the comedy club and me,
tiffany haddish and Tony went across the
street to check out this damn place and
there was like half of the people were
homeless that were just sitting there
spinning their money anywhere though.
But it was,
it was like being in a crack house and
it was just,
it looked like people were doing crack
and people were passed out like a crack
house.
The same thing because crack is like an
elevated thing.
Like you get whacked out.
Right.
But this is just zombied from we'd.
Yup.
Yeah.
And they are really Zombie though,
Joe.
I'm talking about you're looking at a
guy two feet away and you're going to,
this guy's fucking dead and you're doing
comedy for them for the night of the
living dead places.
There's a place in north Hollywood,
so the spot,
the spot where where it's a dive bar and
it's a comedy stage and me and Freddy
Lockhart for try this place for me and
Freddy Book took a hit and then we
walked outside and it makes you cough
and these meet me and Freddy cough for
like 30 minutes and we couldn't even
talk.
I can't breathe and then we had to go on
stage.
Nobody was paying attention.
They were looking through you.
They were like figuring out like talking
to Jerry and you're like,
they have no idea what was going on.
One guy was face down in onto the stage
in front of me and I'm like,
we're going to check on this guy
jokes.
It's amazing.
Their pot really can't kill you.
If you had thought that was some of
these dab guys with some of these people
that are,
that have these crazy contraptions like
these ridiculous vaporizers somewhere
online.
Someone must've fucking hit the wall.
Nobody.
Nobody ever.
I felt like I was dying on wait many
times.
Oh yeah.
Wait,
about five,
six,
seven years ago.
I got back into we big time before I
started comedy and I was like,
Whoa,
this isn't 80 sweet,
you know,
like one hit my heart with Guinness.
It's definitely a totally different
experience.
But apparently this kind of weed was
available if you,
uh,
you check the has been some scientists
that have done some studies on the
different strains and like what the pope
potential potency.
Apparently there was some pretty fucking
strong weed back in the day,
like Acapulco gold used to call it.
You could get ahold of some really
strong weed,
but the strongest we'd today is stronger
than that and that weed was rare.
So like,
you know,
like you'll get a hold of some today,
but that's not that good.
But most of the week today is pretty
fucking good.
It was really rarely you would get like
quality California weed back then I just
asked my uncle at the same thing and I
was like,
you know about it?
He goes,
no,
there,
it was available.
I had heard of it,
but he like,
he's like,
I smoked weed every day.
I never saw it.
I went to Cannabis Cup and uh,
and you,
you,
they take it out there and you can vote
on the weed.
It's in Amsterdam once a year and then
the winners,
it's a big deal because the winter is,
are these seeds for big money.
That was a judge,
judge at one in La.
So it was a blizzard rated.
I have no idea what anything tasted
liked.
White widow number five.
Give me a,
like a box,
like,
and it had,
you know,
all those things that people do for
vitamins where they have Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
it's all labeled and top and you pop up
each individual.
They had one of those filled with weed
and they give it to you a good fucking
luck remembering what anything in that
first three people you try one every
year properly.
It's like relationships.
It's like your friend,
like,
oh,
this is my friend's shit man.
You know,
like they,
they don't check to see if anybody.
And it's also just random.
It's fucking totally random.
Yeah.
Standards Tastes pretty good.
Like some of it has like a different
kind of flavor to it,
but not enough that you had awarded
anything.
I'm a black hash guy.
I'm glad that more than anything it
tastes great.
The what's Black Hash?
Just black cash.
It's like that oily black cash.
It's made out of the oil and you can
kind of pull it off.
Like now it looks like a.
Oh,
like a ball,
like a tar ball.
He peel,
peel a piece off.
It's like,
tastes great man.
And it's a different high.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's when you eating hash,
especially if you're eating it,
if even if you're smoking,
you're getting a different.
It's,
it's like a vaporizer high more than
it's like a joint high.
I like it better to you.
Yeah,
because it's,
I think it's more mellow for me,
you know?
It doesn't seem to grab me and go,
you're heart,
you're shitting your pants.
I always think I'm shitting my pants on
weed.
Like I feel like there's no,
no feeling below.
I usually feel the opposite of feeling
of too much feeling going on all the
different processes that are happening,
feel at all,
but it does loosen up.
The bowels now does get you where you
want to take your Chinese shit.
Scared of.
When was the last time?
When was the last time you smoked weed?
Probably five years ago.
Right when I started comedy I realized I
had to quit because it was wiping out my
short term memory.
I'd be on stage in a bag.
Fuck what's next?
I couldn't remember.
Wow.
I could not remember what was next,
but I can remember 20 years ago and this
was a no party and back then the
drinking was done.
Oh yeah.
I stopped drinking in [inaudible] 92.
No coke,
no booze since [inaudible] 92.
And that's all because of the throat?
Yeah,
pretty much.
And then I realized I gotta get my shit
together.
I burned it up hard joe.
I mean hard.
So like guys like Paul Stanley,
Paul Stanley never drank,
right?
No he didn't.
Those guys were a clean dudes.
But you know,
you can trash your voice.
He you to think Paul every night.
He's like,
yeah,
no,
he,
that's all he ever does.
When he's,
when he's talking,
he's like,
he never stops there.
I must be way easier to sing.
Now.
You got into your monitors there in the
middle.
Get the fuck outta jail with the boys.
You ridiculous Picchu.
Oh my God.
On the left.
That's me with tracie guns from La guns.
What do these guys look like?
They look the same possible.
Fire up a photo.
I think I have a photo like two days
later of La guns have.
Tracy does a podcast with me and right.
There you go.
There's us,
there's tracy on the left.
That's the guy on the right from the
bullet.
Boys do not look the same.
I mean they didn't even remotely.
Glasses.
Look at my shirt,
right?
Snake.
Steven,
right?
It's hilarious.
Steven,
right?
Man,
do you have the picture of you?
And uh,
that's.
There was that dude have a che Guevara
tattooed on his chest.
I wonder how much he really knows about
Che Guevara.
There's a lot of people that got Che
Guevara Tattoos that didn't know a
goddamn thing about Che Guevara.
He just wanted to look cool and I find
it more old pictures of the roses.
It's towards the beginning.
If you're in my instagram,
the beginning of the other one,
it started my instagram feed,
but when you very start,
when I first started out or Jamiel fine.
Yeah,
he'll get it.
So you did it for all those years you
did music and then what,
what made you decide to do like an open
mic night?
Well,
what happened was I stopped playing
music basically because once the
download and came in the illegal
download and there's just no money for
a,
a mid level musician anymore.
You know,
like when I played music,
you can play music for years and just be
touring like the jam bands,
you know,
like a Kinda grateful Dead Blues
Traveler,
Black Crows,
that kind of thing.
And make some money selling cds and
shirts.
But once people just grabbed the cds,
it was out like guys,
we'd come home,
we'd be like,
we got 400 bucks.
We'd been out three months.
Yeah.
So that's cool for me,
but when he got band members with wives,
they're like,
Hey,
you've been gone for three months,
you have no money and no.
So I stopped and I started working at
Harley Harley Davidson.
I was like,
oh,
I guess I'll just do this,
but when you've been on stage 25 years
it starts to fuck with it.
You're like,
man,
I gotta be here at nine and then I got
to be here all day and for selling
bikes.
So you were like a bike sales over in
van nuys.
Wow.
I actually liked it but it was,
it.
It's just so different from us at the
death of a dream.
Like I kinda really felt like that.
Yeah,
I felt pretty,
uh,
I was really depressed and I was angry.
Yeah.
Because I was just kinda like,
fuck these guys,
you know,
you got a guy come in and you spend four
or five hours,
you're on commission and then they go
somewhere else and they come over with
their bike.
Like,
hey man,
look,
I bought one.
They don't know that you're on
commission.
I guess I went over there,
they had,
they gave me a shirt and you're like,
fuck,
I made no money today,
you know?
Yeah.
It really is.
It's annoying.
The annoying thing about being a
salesman,
right?
It's brutal.
But there's
con or comedy as.
I'm not like a sales.
You know what I mean?
Like,
because you're,
you're constantly trying to get stage
time and,
and with sales you're constantly hoping
somebody says yes.
Salesmen is weird too because you're
kind of a professional manipulator and a
lot of,
oh,
it's horrible.
I told her this,
I got a lot of times you feel like a
drug dealer because you're selling
something to somebody that's proud
they're probably going to die on,
you know what I mean?
Like what do you mean?
Because they just don't know.
They don't know how to ride and you're
just there like here,
like,
Hey,
you took the school,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And they're lying and they just rolled
out and he goes,
that guy has no idea.
He's on two wheels and he's going under
fan eyes boulevard right now.
Either one of the most brutal streets.
And I've been watching so many ever
since I got rear ended the other day.
I've been watching so many people
texting in the fucking car.
God Damn folks got to stop doing that.
It's brutal.
Oh everybody
thinks they can pull it off.
And you see people doing this as they're
driving,
looking down and looking up,
looking down,
looking up like fuck.
The amount of time you cover while
you're looking down,
going straight forward before you look
up again.
You're talking about sometimes 20,
30 feet bay at a time and that's 20,
30 feet.
The you didn't hit the brakes at
something popped up in front of you and
that's too late.
And boom.
Old Ladies flying through the air
because you just walked out into
traffic.
Yeah man.
I mean even even when you're not
texting,
how many times did the one on one or
you're like,
well fuck shit,
look at this wall and now you're adding
texting into it.
I've watched some lady with a kid in her
car today.
She was doing that thing that sometimes
people they take driving and the it
turns into like a sport.
They try to like get in front of the car
to the left.
It was a two lane road and she was
trying to get in front of,
there was a guy to my right and there
was a guy that was in front of us.
There was like a little bit of gap
between me and him and she was trying to
speed and get into that gap and right
when she was trying to speed someone
else came into her lane,
they weren't paying attention and she
had a kid in her car and she had a slam
on the brake and go flying into the,
uh,
into the side of the emergency role.
And I watched her do it and I watched
her afterwards.
She was like touching the kid's chest
and talking to him,
trying to console him because the kid
freaked out because she didn't need to
do it.
There was no,
no reason to do it.
And she drove normal.
After that she was behind me.
The entire whale.
I kept an eye on her,
but I was like this,
this was just like a game,
like she wanted to make that gap.
Some
girl I was on Laurel Canyon and she came
right up to me like right onto my ass
and start flashing her lights,
like what the fuck is this lady doing?
And then she tries to pass me and it
pushes me off the side of the road.
As another car starts coming.
Then she slams on the brake,
goes behind me.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Like she literally tried to like
sideswiped me and then she gets ahead of
me and it kept slamming on her brakes
and brake checking me.
So finally,
by the way,
this is all on periscope.
I finally got her ceiling up here.
Now you want to watch wanting to get
past that was like,
look at this guy and I know I have a
dash mount so it's just sitting there.
But then we get to a stoplight and I
could pull up next to.
I rolled down my window like,
what the fuck is your problem?
And said girl with her hair really
short.
She just sitting there like that and she
takes off in front of me and it's
brakes,
checks,
man,
but what the fuck?
A second light,
same thing or whatever.
Hey,
hey Yo,
you and she rolls down the window,
gives me the SMIRK,
like say like,
like that.
And then when it turns white she just
tries to side slamming again.
You should run into her and then killer.
And then periscope.
If I got her license plates,
periscope murder.
I got her license plate number and I
realized how easy it is to get
information from a license plate.
I had no idea.
It's just a $40 google search.
What's her name?
What's his guy?
He's really hot though.
So she gets a pass.
She gets a pass passed so weak you will
live your life in torture and you will
never learn.
That's true.
Bone structure gives her a pass.
She's like half Japanese.
Half Mexican is just what is wrong with
you?
What is wrong with you son?
Somebody sideswiped my car the other
day.
$7,000
worth of damage to my car.
Just parked in front of my street and I
had a drop cam and that that faces my
front of my house and so I caught.
I caught the person like driving by and
it was so fast that I couldn't even see
anything.
It was just like they hit the car behind
me,
hit my car and was going on hammered
probably 30 miles an hour.
Yeah.
Wow.
This happens like once every three
months I'll drive down one of these
little side streets.
I was on a van,
Owen and Van Owen had this car that
someone obviously hit full speed in the
rear and it was parked on the side of
the road because people are texting or
they're drunk or they fall asleep or
something and those cars that are parked
every couple months I'll see one just
caved in on the side of the road and you
know,
someone just drove along and probably
was like looking down at a booty call.
Fuck.
Did you see that one there?
Passed out like a month ago.
She passed out in the middle of the
highway and she just fell asleep,
like pounding on the window.
And she won't wake up and so he had to,
I think he broke the window or something
like that.
I can't remember.
But did she crashed somewhere else?
She just stopped in the middle of the
highway.
Just took a nap.
Cars were like full St Louis.
She parked.
It is right here to turn up the volume
on a freeway.
Cars moving behind the wheel of that
car.
Ten years breaking news track or had the
only camera there is that ran alongside
the car in the middle five.
Try Breaking that window to get the
driver to wake up and get her to HP
officer.
He's risking his life here.
It's on a freeway.
A woman has passed out.
I guarantee you somewhere.
A dude that is like I told you.
I told you that crazy.
That's why we broke up.
She's pretty cute though.
I'd give her a pass.
That's okay.
Honey.
Off It.
You just need a driver.
I remember I was watching the Uber
Dmz and they're like rockstar crushes in
the non cars in Hollywood hills.
Like,
Hey,
I got to see this.
I'm laughing.
And then I knew the guy.
Was it?
It was this Guy Casey from this band a
man.
They're like a kind of a punk metal
band,
but he was,
I guess he was drunk and he hit a car
that he backed up to try to get away and
the front tire came off and he didn't
know she's pressing the gas in the car.
Just drove right into all the other cars
because he had no steering.
Then they added on film.
Oh Man.
It's just unbelievable that you're
expected to drive two bars and then
figuring out how to get home.
That's ridiculous.
The fact that everywhere you looked
there handing out one of the most
ridiculous drugs,
it happens to you.
It almost instantly take a shot of Jack
Daniels within 10 minutes.
You're fucking trash.
How's that bottle of wine legal like
that's like five glasses of wine.
That's way beyond the legal limit for
two people in a dinner,
an hour,
and I only had one when they say that.
If two people just sitting at a dinner
table drinking wine and it's a bottle
and you finish the bottle off your both
hands.
Yeah.
You can't drive.
No,
everywhere you look,
people are driving drunk everywhere you
look.
Friday and Saturday night,
you know,
go to a comedy show,
any comedy show and those people sit
there,
offered the order,
two,
three,
four drinks and then they get out of
there and they drive.
Now it's like for,
for cops must be like the easiest
pickens ever on Friday and Saturday
night and ducks and apparently they have
those new things that you.
For your iphone now it's like a
breathalyzer for your iphone so you can
just sit there and just check every,
you know,
so it's to be a steering wheel thing.
Now there's a new steering wheel they're
developed.
It's going to know if you're drunk.
Well yeah,
it was just a CV to fund the story.
It was just great being handed around
Jesus Today on social media.
So none of us are going to be able to
drive anywhere,
all be stuck at applebee's.
You know,
it's going to be like,
man,
it's going to be like the steroid tests
for the UFC to go,
whoa,
hold up.
Everyone's just fucking completely empty
because no one's car starts.
They would make that legal limit go up
though if that happens.
No,
they were not allowed to have a case of
beer and two shots of.
But no,
they definitely would not.
What they would do is,
uh,
everybody would be hiring their little
brothers and sisters to drive them
around the quiz.
On the right side.
Does bigfoot exists now,
but nothing definite.
That's the type of people that are it.
What is that?
Why k y?
T O wk knows that mountain news.
Oh my God.
Some poll results.
The snow is 73 percent.
Eight point four percent is not sure.
Not sure.
Are the ones that are tuned into
survivor man,
book foot right now.
Man,
I don't know.
When they ask less about the footage,
you said no one really knows whether or
not those boots.
That's enough for me.
That's a no for me.
It looked like a dude in among your
mask,
but I'm telling you what,
I love that big foot thing because just
seeing the guys that they said,
they're the ones that did that photo in
72 or whatever.
Well,
this Patterson Gimlin footage,
there's a guy named Bob [inaudible].
He's the guy who wore the big foot
footage.
You can see those videos of him walking
next to the actual footage of bigfoot
was just like that fucking guy in the
monkey suit.
Jamie.
Jamie,
what are you doing?
You showed it to her.
She pulled it down.
It won't load.
That's legit.
Big Foot.
That is bigfoot's.
Actual foot.
Totally real.
Don't fucking hate bro.
Love.
I love that.
I just thought I grew up in the
seventies.
I love,
uh,
that,
that stuff that Leonard Nimoy would do
like.
Yeah.
Remember he did the Noah's Ark one.
He actually did the full movies.
You could go.
I went to the drive and southern Noah's
arc one and the Ufo one.
Oh,
here it is.
Drunk driving detector.
So how does this work?
According to the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration,
approximately 10,000
people are killed by drunk drivers
annually in the US.
Look at this.
The long arm of the laws handcuffing
this young man and taking him to the
slammer.
Research developing to detection methods
for the driver alcohol detection system.
One method allows the car to analyze a
driver's exhale,
breath for alcohol content.
See,
that's annoying because I had a friend
who got a Dui and they made him do that.
Oh,
they're gonna have like a that just
smells your breath.
Another method shines and infrared light
into your fingertips and it reads it.
Oh,
it was used.
Alcohol limit of ope point zero.
Eight blood alcohol content as it's
standard.
It used to be owed nine right there.
No one was one when I was growing up.
Parents could.
Hmm.
I wonder why they made it my money.
Make money.
If you think that's what it is,
or do you think it's because they
realize that more people are actually
crashing like that?
There must be some scientific basis for
the one point.
Oh,
eight,
isn't there?
I don't know,
but it seems to me that you should be
able to go in and take a test like a
weed smokers as well and be like,
well,
I've been drinking 25 years,
so my limit should be true,
but the problem with that is then you're
going to push it even further.
The guys who go,
look,
I looked,
I did the legal limit.
I'd do three shots,
I can handle five,
come on and you'll just keep pushing it,
but if you know that if you piss or you
blow and oh eight,
you're fucked you,
then you're not going to get drunk now
or if you do,
you can't really argue about it.
I used to do these open mics.
Joe and this girl had the the
breathalyzer on her car and she would
pay guys to go out and breathe in or
ride so she could drive home
[inaudible].
She would be drunk like where do you do?
And so it looks like it's [inaudible]
98.
In March of 98,
President Clinton called for the
promotion of a national legal limit
under which it would be illegal per se,
to operate a motor vehicle with a blood
alcohol concentration of point zero
eight or higher across the country,
including federal property.
He was just trying to get people to not
pay attention to this extra dirty freak.
That guy,
that guys.
That was the last ones are the ones like
and fucking relate to the real
presidential dick slingers.
I can't wait for him to be back in the
history.
Oh yeah,
100 percent.
I don't think so.
They did some polls,
man.
After the emails and stuff,
people are just like,
they're looking.
First of all,
people were looking for a reason to not
like her because she's a woman.
Let's just get that out of the way and
the fact that she's a woman that's also
a Clinton and it's a Clinton versus a
bush.
People are fucking totally tired of this
dynasty thing that's been going on for
the past x amount of decades where they
just going back and forth,
Bush to Bush to Bush.
I mean the idea of a Jeb Bush became
president after his brother fucked
everything up and then his dad fucked
everything up before that and if that's
not our option,
then the Clinton option and it's Hillary
and Hillary.
Hillary is.
She's tied to a bunch of shady fucking
things.
That property stuff.
Yeah,
the Whitewater Shane from back in that
thing that it's Arkansas,
the Vince foster thing.
There's a lot of like weird shit,
but that's the case with anybody that's
involved in like high level politics
like that.
There's,
there's.
They got some shit on you before you
ever even get in there.
Otherwise you don't get in there.
You can't be a politician to be clean.
That's impossible.
There's no way.
You literally can't get to the highest
level where you're running for president
unless you've been completely
compromised by special interest groups.
That's the only way those cancer
campaign contributions are critical and
you have to sit down with those fucking
corporation owners and the CEOS and
they.
They figure out what the fuck is going
to go down,
like how,
how laws are going to be structured,
what influence is going to get them.
If this person gets into our office,
they don't.
They're not ambiguous about it.
Now like maybe I can help you if I get
in,
give me a million bucks and went back
and help you.
They know that this guy is going to make
either regulations more relaxed or
figuring out how to push things through
or figure out that that's what politics
are.
It's all money now,
it's the whole ball of wax when they
talk about like the amount of time that
a guy actually spends campaigning and
trying to raise money,
like as opposed to how much time they
spend on actual work.
It's.
It's astounding.
Campaign is all about raising money.
I take their whole thing is about
raising money and occasionally giving
speeches.
That's crazy,
right?
It's just whoever gets the most money
wins,
Donnelly.
That you would have to have some insane
amount of money spent just to try to
make it into those debates.
Just to try to get into the baits.
Like the commission for presidential
debates is a privately owned
corporation,
are privately owned institution.
Like you can't just get in the debate.
You can't say,
Hey,
I'm Dean del Rey and I've got some
pretty good ideas and I'd like to run
for president.
No,
you have to.
You have to get more than I believe 15
percent on five different polls and it's
the polls that day choose like they can.
They can cherry pick.
Like say if you're a guy like Ross Perot
type guy that might fuck things up for
them.
They didn't anticipate that when Ross
Perot came around and he spent a
shitload of his own money,
tried to run for president,
ruined all their plans
right away.
Afterwards they monkeyed with the
numbers and change things.
It made it even more difficult for an
independent person to debate and the
presidential elections.
So to the average American,
there's only two choices.
You see those two assholes on,
on television.
You have your Republican debates and you
have your democratic debates,
and then when it breaks down to those
two guys,
those are the only two people running
for president as far as you know,
that's.
That's a broken system.
Like I'm 49.
How old are you?
40 seven.
I'll be 48 in August.
Do you remember a good president?
Yeah,
will clam was good.
People liked Clinton until he got caught
getting a blowjob.
Carter Carter man,
Carter Sweetie.
He smoked weed with what?
Elvis on the roof.
That's cool.
Did he had the White House?
That's what they say.
Know?
I never heard that.
It's one of those fucking a rainbow bar
and grill.
Family stories.
No,
I think it was like in an elvis song
from motorhead.
Tell you ever played a spaghetti.
One time I met Elvis.
He smoke weed with Jimmy Dean.
Was it you that told me that?
That,
that classic Ron Jeremy Story about the
rainbow and he is sleeping now.
Nevermind.
Supposedly he had.
He's a narcoleptic or he just finds
Jeremy Ron,
Jeremy Sleep all the time and supposedly
he was at the rainbow and I forget who
told me this story.
He says they looked over and ron just
went spaghetti and fell asleep and
getting the night somebody put him up
and he had like spaghetti all over him
and stuff.
But here it is.
Oh Willie.
Oh,
Willie Nelson and chip Carter.
Chip car smoked a joint together on the
White House.
Oh,
sees.
See how the story changes harder though.
Let's tell the stories.
That's how that game of telephone grid
telephone works.
It was like shipped Carter's Jimmy
Carter's son.
Is that what it is?
It must be right.
That's not the one that shipped Carter
running.
What's he doing,
man?
Because his brother had belly beer.
Billy Carter was a mess and Clinton have
a fucking mess of a brother too.
I don't remember the mess of a brother.
Kai.
That's great.
Yeah.
The mess,
brother.
That almost ruins it for everybody.
Smoked any of the Willie weed.
He's got his own weed.
No,
no.
Everyone has.
Everyone has a skin diamond.
Has her own leader.
Just like four different strains named
after me.
I had one of them.
Yeah.
This.
You can't look whatever the Willie
Nelson weed is.
He probably has nothing to do with it.
Yeah,
right.
It's just they're paying him.
Jimmy Carter was one of the guys that I
was.
I remember being young and listening to
them talk and I believed him.
She was sincere in a way that a lot of
these guys just don't.
Some guys just.
They seemed so phony.
Carter,
whether or not you agree with them or
disagree with him.
He seemed sincere and then it always
bugged me that the Republicans had
negotiated to release the hostages in
Iran after Reagan was in office,
so they had.
They had made it a part of the
negotiation to not release those people
to make them look.
I can hear right,
but that that means that those people
had to stay prisoner longer just for
politics.
Yeah.
I mean the Republicans at the time
should have been shunned just for that.
Someone should have pointed that out.
If they could prove it,
that's if that was true.
I don't know if that is true though.
That might be one of those sessions.
Be Carter on the roof with Elvis.
Carolyn with Andrew.
It's actually Maroon five doing when you
remember those gas wars.
Joe Green Day with the odd and even
plates.
You could only buy gas every other day.
Whatever your last number on your
license plate was because the kids don't
remember that.
That was crazy out here.
Are We?
Oh yeah.
Where'd you grow up?
I was the east coast.
It was in California.
I didn't even play.
I thought it was across the nation,
but you could only buy gas on every
other day if whatever your last number
on your license plate was.
Task Wars.
It makes no sense at all.
What if you just happen to run out of
gas so you couldn't do anything?
Well,
it was during that whole.
that was the one who started making
those really economical car.
So it was when they were trying to
figure out the Saudi oil situation.
Yeah,
they were trying.
That's when cars turned to shit.
Exactly.
When cars went from being these awesome
beasts to these dog shit.
Cars.
Dog should car the seventies,
the sixties,
sixties or seventies is the worst
dropoff of,
of American cars ever.
It took us until like the 2004 we
recovered.
Yeah.
Like remember the Mustang to.
Oh,
piece of shit.
All those mustangs in the late seventies
into the eighties mustang with ugly
plastic nonsense.
You go back to [inaudible] 69,
mach one.
Just look at one of those and then look
at what happened in the eighties.
Like how did you guys fall so far off?
I.
How did you do this?
Isn't that crazy?
Because that was mock ones are
beautiful.
All those old cars to this day.
To this day,
I mean,
it might not be the most arrogant.
They might not be the best as far as
like the wind resistance and all that
shit,
but as far as like the looks.
Oh,
I had a dodge super B,
70.
It was a great car selling it right now
for my buddy.
I sold it to him 13 years ago.
Now he's selling it.
He's had it forever but is a listing for
it.
We'll get it sold right now.
Oh yes.
Listed.
Just email me.
Dean del Ray.
Don't say a fucking tsunami warning
email.
You almost did it.
Released your email address.
I think there's a picture of it on my
instagram now.
It says B,
five blue and it's got the c stripe and
the crazy and it's just when you look at
those cars and think that you could walk
a car lot and 70 now I go,
let me get that race car.
Well that's what they're doing today.
They are.
I love the hell cat to all these cars
today.
They're way better.
This is the first time where the new
American cars,
like the DOJ,
they drive is so much better than the
old ones,
but still the old ones,
they still look better.
Better.
There's something about them like a 69
Camaro.
There's something about.
It was just like you can't.
He can't beat it.
They got that,
has that classic muscle car,
loved that car with the hideaway
headlights.
The four on the floor.
He had the tick tock gauges and the
wooden dash and wood steering wheel.
Right.
And the console.
I had to have a man at the console and
eight track player man.
Those cars,
they just nailed it.
They nailed it for between 65 and it's
tough to go after [inaudible] 73 now.
Seventy three Kudos are still bad ass at
73.
I think they still made a challenger in
73,
but everything else,
dog shit.
That was the end.
And the cars had already lost their
power.
They were already like butchering the
power on them yet,
but seventies cause the last hurrah.
Seventy,
71 car.
I love the 69.
Super B with the a 4:46
pack and the pistol grip shifter,
you know?
Yeah.
By the time 70 rolled around,
Mustang had already taken a downturn.
It's true.
They're just started to look weird and
then.
But the but the but,
but by the time 70 rolled around the,
the Kuda was just getting started as
kills the Kuda suck before 70.
Sure.
I had the coo to the first one where it
was and it was shorter and funky.
Then they dumped the era and make it
longer or they make a big body and it's
killer,
but they only nailed it for three years.
Can you imagine that?
They wouldn't.
Seventy two,
73 and then everything after that,
it's gone.
It's true.
Barracuda had it.
So that was the last spark of the muscle
car.
That was the last remaining era.
And now sometimes you'll see one go for
a million bucks,
like Cuda convertible.
Purple made three.
$1,000,000
more an hour.
Now Barry Jackson more.
Now they're going for more.
I know private collections that uh,
they sell.
They have like this rk motors in
Charlotte,
they have this big website filled with
them and they had one on sale for more
than a million bucks.
It's crazy numbers matching ones.
Yeah.
I love that shit man.
I'll talk to for hours on cars were the
nuts man and I just like this one,
you know,
and I'll send them a photo in the middle
of the night.
He'll be like,
Nah,
this one.
Well Corvette had some good years after
[inaudible] 69.
They had the 70 vet was still in those.
Those sting raises to a pretty bad car.
Seventy three is the last year and that
once they get rid of that steel bumper,
it's out.
You know that same thing.
Yeah.
Seventy three was the last acceptable
year for a muscle car.
Yeah.
Weird.
It is weird.
He tried to sell someone a 75 muscle
card.
Good luck.
I'll tell you what,
I do have jail shit away from me.
Nobody wants it.
I loved the 78 Trans six point
six.
The Burmese.
That's a true.
That's true.
That's the only car though in the
seventies.
The Burt Reynolds is that website I
bought.
This is where I'm.
I bought my corvette.
Oh my God.
Look at that.
Sixty eight.
Fort Shelby right there.
The Lord.
What are there?
You got 69 in the middle.
They're black like in that one there.
One hundred 9,000.
See,
I like my car stock that I don't like
when they're all phased out.
I don't dare you get a new car for that.
Those stock ones drive like shit though.
I know,
but you just have it for the burger that
for 2017.
That's what it see where it says pro
touring.
Those pro touring cars with.
That means they take an old muscle car
and they put the most modern suspension
on it.
Like chip foose,
red handle.
We'll chip is more of a designer and you
know,
chip does a lot of different
modifications to cars to make them look
cool.
Look at that.
70 Chevelle super sport.
Convertible debt.
Get Cocker,
scrolled down.
This 70 Chevelle convertible more.
That makes my dick look at that.
Look at that fucking car and the
restart.
Oh my God.
Look it.
Eight hood.
That's my favorite hood.
That fucking car.
Can we see the interior?
Like lease console?
That's like a perfect combination to
have the wheels.
The wheels are like they're modern
wheels.
A vintage Erin.
The radio is dope.
Like at the top aunt.
Then I look at that top.
Will leak after data away.
He stayed down.
No,
no,
it won't leak because these are all new
that everything's new and used cars.
Wow.
Look at that.
God.
The console with the forest speed.
Unbelievable.
One hundred 49.
That's the fucking car right there.
Look at that car.
Just gives you a man bone.
Gives me a boner for that.
Even for sex though.
No,
no,
I got.
So you just want to try.
Just drive around hard trunk.
This was the last uh,
last couple of years of the Chevelle to
let's just Chavela was bad ass and 67
and 68.
I just wonder what the carbon fibers
valve covers.
See that?
Holy Shit.
That's a pro.
Yeah,
it's an ls three.
That's a six point two Liter v eight
from a corvette.
Oh,
Joe.
Is it hard not to just buy every single
car?
Yeah,
you gotta you gotta be an adult.
You pulled out into the store with that.
I would just fuck it if you see my
corvette.
No,
my Corbett's coulier Oh,
what year?
60 five.
60 five pro touring convertible.
The entire suspensions redone.
Fully independent function.
Silver,
silver.
But I uh,
sent it down to Steve Strope.
Steve Strope is this a hot rod builder
in California?
And I had them change some things on it
and approve the suspension.
That's the kind like that one right
there.
The 64.
Exactly.
Like mine.
Oh my dad had 65 solid it when I was
born in [inaudible].
60 six.
I got a photo of it.
Him and my mom in front of it to the
best.
I'll send you the photo and you can look
at is cool.
I'll show.
I'll bring that car to the store when
it's finished.
It's almost done now.
I love those.
They were called the black widow.
The one on the left.
The 64 with the.
Yeah,
there.
Go to that one.
I love that.
I love that car.
There's such radical designs or
corvette.
God,
what a car.
I'll come.
They didn't do that at all.
They do sort of.
Dude pulled up the 2015 corvette Z.
Oh,
love it.
Check this out because this right now is
a new car the corvette has created.
That is as fast as a lot of cars that
cost a million bucks.
Oh yeah.
This is an insane car.
I mean,
you'd probably have to spend a million
bucks to beat it at this.
Go to the blue.
That's the beef.
I love the next one over right there.
The light bulb got you.
Don't like that.
Start drinking again.
Know it's pretty dope.
The actual car itself and the little
swatch looks gross.
Yeah,
yeah,
right.
Oh yeah.
Thomas.
But pull up a video of one of these
because once you see it in action,
that's where it's ridiculous that this
is a 600 horsepower race car that you
can buy straight from the factory.
It's less than $80,000.
Yeah,
I mean you can get one stripped out for
like 80 grand and it'll burry like most
really high end sports cars.
It's insane.
The,
the.
This is the,
this is the race version.
You're looking at Jamie,
this is the development of the race,
the actual race version,
a youtube video,
and you can see a guy.
He's racing one on the garage.
Go to jail.
Was Raj?
Yup.
There you go.
Right there.
Oh,
because it'll get us band.
Okay.
We'll just watch it without showing it
to the rest of the world.
But these a liquid.
Well they.
This is the problem with this car though
that bums me out,
is that they're making this thing with
an automatic.
The old zero six in the car.
One.
The only way you could get it was it had
to be a stick shift.
I left the car.
One fucking man.
Remember that one day maybe shifting or
even a woman.
A woman is exciting.
They made one like five years ago,
[inaudible].
It was blue with the glass top and they
only made like 50 of them and that thing
was insane.
It was like no,
been around for a long time.
They've made it for a long time,
but it was only available in a stick.
J Dot Lana would never buy it in
anything other than a stick because he's
a fucking man.
Yeah.
He wears jeans.
Shirts 2015.
Look at him,
look at the APP right there.
He's got a one style of shirt that he
allows himself.
Hey guys,
let's,
uh,
don't get it twisted.
I don't give a fuck if I get like the
guys feel comfortable.
My sleeves are rolled up because I work
hard at the,
at the garage.
Do you know it's.
Once he stopped,
stopped TV.
He got rid of that black dot that was in
the middle of his head that he started
freaking out and he wasn't totally great
time.
Got Older,
but yeah,
I'm,
I'm doing his show.
His show was supposed to have already
happened,
but that dude rear ended me.
He's got a Joe.
He's got a 36 knucklehead,
which is considered the best harley of
all time.
I watched the footage of him last week
driving it a riding.
It all originally never restored it.
He found in a barn.
Didn't start it for like 20 years and
decided,
well,
let's try that thing out.
And he started up and took her for a
ride and I lose my mind when I see it.
30 six knuckle.
It's a one year motorcycle.
Wow.
And he has it a CV looking at real
quick.
Hold on a second
while we're still on it.
This car is the 1965.
And while we're on this video,
before we change,
this is the 1965 of 2015.
I mean this car when,
when all said and done and people look
back and like the golden era of muscle
cars,
they came back in a big way like the new
mustangs have.
You've seen the new shelby?
The 2015.
I love shelby.
Three-Fifty.
The GT three slash 50.
It's insane.
So beautiful car.
They were,
they were doing the sound of it
yesterday on Yahoo.
They said it was the best uh,
exhaust note ever done.
And you listen to it.
It needs to go listen to this car.
Let's pull that up.
Shelby gt three slash 15 slash 2015.
It's incredible.
Have 16 because it's not,
it's not released.
It's not yet.
Yeah.
Have you seen the 2015 sienna,
Toyota,
Sienna?
No.
Pull up the exhausts.
Just heard.
It's.
Yeah,
it's good.
They call it the greatest.
Wouldn't be November 17th because he
said it just came out and that was
yesterday.
I'm like,
yeah,
no.
Yeah,
try Yahoo.
Is that it?
Noise regulations in America since for
was not able to make the gt through
screaming at the top of that.
We'll try that.
Yeah.
Let's take out.
What does that say exhausts us?
Nodes.
You can change it.
That they,
uh,
the set here.
Let's hear.
Yeah.
It was such losers.
That sounds like a drag when you open up
the scanner.
Wow.
That's a muscle man.
That's one of the greatest sounds of
muscle cars ever made.
Women.
That's a god Damn Dragon.
It's a dragon.
It's glorious.
Oh my God.
Gloria sounds.
Don't get better than that.
It's so great,
man.
That's rock and roll and I'm pretty sure
they only make that one in a stick
shift.
Praise Allah.
Praise.
Praise store.
She can't be making that fucking thing
in an automatic to stop.
Learn how to drive a stick.
You don't appreciate what the fuck
you're doing.
La Mans Talk.
It is this tall.
I've never driven a stick.
It's not as fun.
In bumper to bumper traffic,
bumper to bumper traffic sucks.
No matter what you do.
If you only gonna have one car that you
drive around and you want total
convenience.
Yes,
automatic.
But if you want to be a fucking man,
okay,
you gave yourself a goddamn stick shift
and you deal with it.
You deal with that bumper to bumper in
San Fran,
man,
for you.
Just hills on the hills.
He is learned.
Steve Mcqueen a few times,
just drunk jumping hills.
Hey,
I was in echo park last week.
They got hills over there.
I've never been three streets.
They say are the tallest hills in
California above San Fran.
Really?
You can't even see down.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
I was on my bike.
I was like,
this is scary as shit in echo park,
three hills.
I've never been there ever.
I just.
I always find it hilarious when you see
those houses in San Francisco that
literally have to be smushed up next to
each other because they're both leaning
sideways on this fucking hill trying to
stay straight,
connected each other and like the hill
is,
and then the bottom of the houses,
it's like a triangle to wedge it in as
like when you look at the actual frame
of the house and the way the foundation
is wedged into the hill,
you'll like,
this is ridiculous.
Can you imagine building those crazy
like no one's going to buy these and
they all sell.
And then the other problem is if one of
them catches on fire,
done,
it goes right through all the houses
because these fucking assholes are glued
next to each other.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Have fires,
man.
San Francisco has some bad fires.
They got a history of it.
I mean that 89 earthquake,
the entire,
uh,
marina burned down to the ground because
that's,
uh,
was built on landfill sand.
And then the shit start,
the earth moved and the house is sunk
and the gas lines cracked.
And the whole thing went up in flames
that took like a day to just put out the
fire.
So that whole place was burning to the
ground.
Eighty nine.
Imagine what that looked like.
A forced CNN.
Imagine whole cnn back then they did on
the bay bridge over and over when it
drops down.
And the car falls.
Yeah.
I watched that live from,
from Boston.
That's where I was like,
Fuck California before I moved here.
It felt like an actual.
It wasn't a quake where you're like,
Whoa,
this is a big one.
It was more like waves.
So I can.
I was watching the 89 world series.
It was giants a's.
First time ever.
You're like,
this could be great.
Bay Bay Bridge World series.
And I come out in the living room and
the fucking four's going like this,
like Whoa,
what?
And then you realize what's going on.
I'm
scared.
Me Too.
That shit is real right there.
Look at that right there.
And then they other mad drove off.
So the lady drove off the top of it.
Yeah,
she was on the top.
And then the thing dropped and she went
down.
I think the other piece crunch people
below,
you know,
a credit spread or you know,
somewhere someone skimped on some
construction costs.
All that is gone now,
right?
No.
The down part is.
That's the first part.
Oh no,
that's gone.
Yeah,
The first part says suspended bridge and
the new part,
the new parts.
Cool.
You seen it show the new bridge?
No,
I don't think so.
It's an intention.
It's like Super Art Deco.
When I lived in San Francisco,
I lived there from age seven to 11.
I experienced the tiniest little baby
earthquake were the windows rattled and
I freaked out because it was a little
kid.
He was there as a kid from seven to 11.
Oh,
that's right.
What were your parents down there?
My Dad was.
My stepdad when I was a kid was a
computer programmer and then you want to
be an architect.
So we moved from New Jersey to
California and lived in San Francisco.
Wow.
For those five years.
And um,
when,
uh,
when I was here I was always scared of
it.
But that one little one,
it was just a little baby one just north
of route on the windows and I remember
like,
Whoa,
just this feeling of helplessness and
weirdness and then I didn't experience
an actual one and even that was a baby
one until 94.
I was here after the big earthquake and
experienced some aftershocks where I was
in a shitty apartment in north
Hollywood.
And I remember the feeling that,
you know,
those refrigerator boxes,
like someone will buy a refrigerator and
then the kids would play in the box and
so on.
But you know how the box like it would.
Oh yeah,
it would just move like really weekly.
You could push it back and forth.
That's what the department felt like.
It felt like a refrigerator box.
I was like,
this is crazy because I was in north
Hollywood,
which isn't too far from North Ridge.
That was the epicenter,
right?
Yeah.
And uh,
this shitty apartment that I was in was
just made out a fucking hopes and dreams
and sliding back and forth.
And then I've experienced a couple that
are similar to that,
like five and a half,
five point four years,
something like that.
But I've never experienced a real one.
The real ones are supposed to be life
changing.
Do you see that movie yet?
I saw it.
I love the Rock,
but I'm not going to go.
Life is precious that they're trying to
limit my movie.
Going to movies that don't suck.
That's not taking over yesterday's.
Would you say that
the one about Brian Wilson,
that beach boys one.
What is it?
What's it called?
It's called love and mercy.
And it's a,
the kid from the um,
there will be blood and little Miss
Sunshine.
The guy that didn't talk on that movie,
he plays Brian Wilson and it's about the
era of a smile and pet sounds.
It's so cool.
Smile and pet care to pet sounds was the
record that the Beatles said,
oh my God,
we've got to make sergeant peppers will.
Yeah.
Because it was like,
it was a one man genius.
Basically heard all these sounds and his
fucking head and made this record.
Pet sounds.
And a beach boys record after they're
like,
oh,
we're so they get into this like dark
crazy record one guy.
Yeah.
I never knew that they need a guy,
Brian Wilson.
He goes his vision.
Yeah.
And the other guys were out on tour and
he is like,
you guys gone on tour and I'll just make
a record when you come back,
you'll sing on it.
And he just made this fucking like
legendary record of layered sounds and
instruments and,
and uh,
insane.
It's really insane.
What should we listen to?
Like what song?
Oh,
let me see the track listing rally.
Um,
it's,
you know that.
Oh God only knows right there.
That's the one right there.
That's really the one they,
they,
uh,
is that right there?
That's.
God only knows.
Yeah.
So you can see where beetles get started
to pepperdine.
Wow.
This is the beach boys.
It's arguably one of the top five albums
of all time.
He took acid and,
and he starts taking acid.
Why have I never heard of this?
It's incredible Jeff.
That's cool.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
You might not like with either.
Probably not going to like this.
Let's.
Anyway,
those guys gave me a copy of the jets.
Great.
60 six.
Huh?
Give me a copy.
What do you live in the eighties?
How are you going to give it to every
quarter to just set duel Deborah Shit.
I can get it through the air on my own.
I need you to give me something that I'm
going to lose.
Is downloaded the whole album.
Right?
What am I going to do with that?
Once I get it,
I haven't stuck a fucking CD in my car
and ages.
This is a DVD for my kids.
That's the only time.
Hard disks anymore for my kids.
I'm like,
I'm that guy that needs the product and
like I feel like the man,
they're ripping me off.
I got to have the heart.
Okay.
Product.
Do you have an album that you used to
roll joints in?
People used to roll joints.
This is separate.
The seeds.
They have sleeves that were a look like
acid paper and like rolling.
You can rolling paper.
Which band came with Chung?
Big Bamboo record came with a giant one
and everybody world.
The big one pounder joint with it.
That's hilarious.
Great.
Yeah.
They used to have seeds and we'd.
Oh God,
it would pop.
It'd be smoking.
There we go.
Pop.
And it would stick.
And you go fucking seeds.
Yeah man.
You'd have to like sort it out.
Like I remember guys had have to sort
out.
You'd break it up and then you would be
doing all this sorting before you rolled
a joint and you throw it in your
backyard and go,
well good luck on that.
Didn't go anywhere.
Right?
Well there was all kinds of different
ways that you would get seeds with.
And then it wasn't until like,
I don't know,
when did they start having no seeds?
I came along to we'd late,
I think that has seats.
I've always,
always Mexican brick weed for me.
Press it all together.
And so it come in this brick,
you'd have stems and seeds and you break
it apart and then uh,
you know,
roll it up.
But once that indycar like up and uh,
you know,
nor cal,
when they started growing that kill or
those cola buds,
there was no seeds and that shit,
it was just giant Koala buds and
everybody's like,
Whoa,
indicus here.
The new weed off
we'll out of figure out was how to
genetically like not engineer with like
chemicals,
but splicing and using.
Once those gaps,
those botanists got ahold of weed.
That's when Shit got interesting.
All they needed was just enough
comfortable space where they didn't feel
like they were gonna go to jail.
Just give them enough.
So Humboldt was like,
where a lot of that stuff came from
because like that whole economy up there
is based on weed.
Oh,
tell her I say the Emerald Triangle
documentary.
It's unbelievable.
I haven't seen it,
but I know a lot of people grow up
there.
Yeah,
me too.
And it's like without that,
that,
that whole area has gone.
Yeah.
That's what's weird because logging went
away and a lot of those guys actually
voted against legalization,
which is really fucked up.
Yeah.
Because they want the money.
They would butcher the prices.
And uh,
if it was,
it was easy,
you know,
if it was easy to grow and nobody had
ever run any risk,
then it wouldn't be worth it.
They're out of business.
It's not fucked.
Pat Is fucked.
They also voted against like the one of
the doctors that I've been to for
recommendations for prescriptions,
he told me that like,
he's like,
quite honestly,
I know doctors that are voting against
legalization because they want to keep
it medical because you've got to keep
going to the doctor every year and pay a
fee in order to get your license
renewed.
And I'm just like,
Whoa,
it's all money.
Think of that.
I go,
that's fucked.
I got money.
I go,
how does that make you feel?
And he's like,
well,
I feel like I have to adjust my
business.
But the right thing to do is to vote for
legalization.
I'm like,
that's what he says,
that's going to immediately go out and
vote no.
Be on Dr Phil the next day with a tie.
I want to get high and to get right now.
No,
no.
I'm on my bike.
No,
ain't no fucking motorcycle.
Have a navigation system on your
motorcycle?
Uh,
well I can run it through my phone.
That's cool.
Yeah.
I see those things on the new Harley
commercials with the other navigation
screen or like this is nuts.
Like they have,
they have,
but I feel like a motorcycle should be a
motorcycle.
You feel like you should see fucking
gauge cluster.
And that's it.
That's what I got.
When I see the phone ringing,
it's Bluetooth into your motorcycle.
I'm like,
Ooh,
I got Kinda.
It's,
I get it.
I get that.
That's convenient.
But she seems weird that in the helmet,
like Stereo.
So you just turned on like 10 and
you're.
And you're just blasting Zeplin.
Oh,
you've seen this heads up display that's
going to go right into your eye.
That will gouge out your brain.
That's a stupid one.
There's a better one where it's up in
here.
It's just like right here and you don't
see it and you can see behind you.
That is a big risk that guys.
Kate,
take a,
putting that metal square by inches from
his eyes that that's stupid.
Knowing that he's going to be crashing
that bike,
the great likelihood at least once in
his life.
Have you had a bad crash thing?
It's so funny,
man.
I always talk about people like there's
two things I hate when you're riding the
one guy that comes up and we got you
crashed yet.
Which if you did,
you don't want to relive it with a
stranger.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah,
let me just tell you about how bad I
crashed.
I've been trying to forget it and the
other one is I had one of those.
They always tell you they had some year
they had and they didn't have it in l
and it sell it.
Got,
you know,
wife had the kids.
It's just like those are the two things
I hate,
but no,
never crashed.
Those poor bastards.
Look at you and get you out there and
living the dream.
When I used to live the dream,
I used to go out there and risking at
feeding off the adrenaline ticket
chances,
cutting lanes.
I had some friends from Canada,
from Alberta,
and they had never been to California
before and they didn't know that you
were allowed to cut lanes and so these
people would drive.
They're like,
what the fuck is going on?
These people are mania.
They're flying by him with the highway.
They were freaking out because you can't
do that in Canada state.
It's a really new,
believe it only state is it really the
own fucking statement.
And they just pat where he passed it
like two weeks ago.
That's so crazy.
I can't believe it.
It's such a bad law.
So horrible.
It sucked.
Um,
especially with people texting.
Oh,
I get it for them.
It's awesome.
You're stuck on the four or five.
Everybody else is dead and you're
moving.
That is awesome.
I totally get it from their point of
view,
but from a safety point of view,
how the fuck.
First of all,
why do I have to wear a seatbelt if this
dude doesn't even have a fucking shell
on?
He's on a bike.
I have to have a seatbelt.
This fucking guy is even surrounded by
anything.
They just did a study
for two years straight and fanned out.
Splitting lanes is safer than sitting in
traffic because the texters are crashing
into dudes.
That's true.
They're just like texting and boom.
They hit the guy on the bike and it's
also not illegal to do it in shorts.
How that's the dumbest fucking thing.
When you see people with a short sleeve
shirt on or no sleeves in shorts,
like how come I have to wear a seatbelt
or I'll tell you what.
You want to Google a man rides
motorcycle thongs.
It'll fucking make you throw up.
I don't need.
I see guys in thongs around La riding
scooters.
So just hoping you talk about them.
You're talking about them on a podcast.
I'll look at their feet.
Their feet are bad.
Google it,
man.
I get broken off.
Oh yeah.
When they crashed the concrete there.
Barefoot,
barefoot.
Equal concrete.
Sixty,
barefoot plus concrete.
Ooh,
Jesus Christ.
That's a mess.
That's ugly.
That's.
You'd never walk right again.
It's so.
Grow into the rainbow with your fucking
dean always makes me nervous.
So he,
like,
he,
because he drives his motorcycle to like
San Diego or Arizona and stuff like
that.
In that one,
like recently there was like that big
storm and the whole time you're coming
back driving through like rain.
That was,
how do you drive through that?
Can you even see or he hit one puddle,
wouldn't you just spin out?
Well,
I'm not stupid like,
but that got caught.
I was uh,
I ride everywhere.
I have no car,
so I've done all my spots on
motorcycles.
So I go to San Diego and I'm doing the
weekend and it Saturday night I usually
leave Saturday night after the three day
weekend,
a ride home,
but it was rain and I go to sleep and
wake up.
The next day I wake up,
it looks pretty clear.
Hey,
get on the bike.
And as soon as I get out of San Diego by
the checkpoint there it starts fucking
pouring man like I hadn't seen in La and
years.
And I'm like,
well this is it man.
I got a windshield,
you know?
And I just,
I just go because it's one of those
things where you're broke so you go,
well do I spend money on a motel six
here on the side of the highway or just
try to make it.
And I rolled with,
it took me about three hours and it was
funny,
right when I got to Disneyland it
totally stopped raining and by the time
I was home I was completely dry.
Really?
Yeah.
Because it was like sun out and you know
there's another 40 minutes on the bike
and the sun even bad.
No,
it's not that bad.
But it seems like that drive in the rain
is probably really fucking hard to see.
Right.
It's hard to see in.
It's super nerve racking because the
trucks are sprain.
Big Spray.
It's the trucks,
the 18 wheelers that are on the five,
they're spraying big time and you're
like,
Whoa,
fuck.
So you're just trying to go wake far out
to the left.
Them.
It's potential wiping out.
Must be really fucking keeping your,
your senses on the edge.
Huh?
Brutal.
Joe.
I'll tell you one time I had to,
I had to do this Gig in Bakersfield,
uh,
like two years in and I was like,
I can't cancel.
They won't ever booked me again.
And I wrote up the five,
the grapevine.
It got to the top.
It was snowing like a light snow.
Oh No.
My thumb,
my right thumb was frozen to where I was
like,
I couldn't get it anywhere.
Like my thumb was numb.
It was like,
you've frozen barehanded.
No,
I got gloves,
but you're going and your hand is tucked
here so you're cool.
But the thumb was out like this and I
was going to fuck my right thumb is
frozen man.
I don't feel it's.
I pull up in a truck stop and I was
drinking hot chocolates and I bought
some kids mittens and put them
underneath my glove.
So I put these mittens on and then my
gloves and I get to the Gig and there's
like nine people there.
Nine people at a bar gig risked your
life.
I know.
I was like,
what the fuck?
I was so mad.
And then I did 15 minutes and turned
around and rode home.
Oh my God fucked.
He also told me something.
I didn't know that when people flick
cigarettes out there that it actually
sometimes gets into motorcycles,
like coats.
It had one go down my shirt.
I almost crashed these people,
they flick cigarettes out all day long,
all fucking day long.
And they don't even care.
Just boom.
One went down my shirt and I was riding
going,
oh fuck.
Oh.
And I couldn't get over because I was in
traffic.
And I was like,
what the fight?
It's just burning me s on my chest.
He just sent like a man and just touch.
I got it out of your chest.
I got over.
Fucking madness.
Can understand.
I scream at people,
man,
you know,
my buddy got hit two dragonflies.
Fucking we're going around a turn 90.
They were stacked on top each other.
We're riding like CHP style,
mma next to each other.
We go around a turn and I see him.
His arm flies off his fucking handlebar
and he's like,
well,
and the bite,
I go,
well this guy is going down.
What happened,
I thought he was having a heart attack
because guys have heart attacks and
strokes and shit.
I look in my rear view mirror and I've
gone and he's pulled over.
His face is split open because he got
cut from hitting these things that like
90 and they were two dragonflies or like
just like sandpaper that hit him in the
face and he's like,
dude,
I almost die.
Two dragonflies.
Fucking.
That's why you have to have goggles.
I wear a full face.
I don't fuck around and that's why some
people don't.
They have those little skullcaps on
sunglasses.
Dumb a bro.
I'm a rebel.
Some people ride around with no helmets
and other states.
So you get to Arizona doing
comedy and Arizona.
Everyone's riding route.
Sure.
Fuck.
Is there a seatbelt law in Arizona?
Yeah.
Plus plus motorcycles.
How Arizona is a state.
It's one of those people don't think of
it.
You think of it as like white people and
like you think of it as like Arizona's
like golfers or something like that.
A lot of people think of it as a
Scottsdale.
Yeah,
Tucson or a tempe rather like real nice,
cute.
But no,
a big part of Arizona is the wild
fucking west guns anywhere concealed
carry.
Like I had a friend,
uh,
who,
he has a lot of guns and he got pulled
over in Arizona and he had to tell the
cop that he has guns in the trunk and
the guy,
the cops,
like,
wow,
what do you shoot?
And they started having a fucking cool
gun conversation.
The guy.
Well I just let me check real quick,
make sure everything's in order and
everything was in order.
All right man,
we'll take it easy.
Enjoy your second amendment rights.
That fucking pound knuckles and go about
their business to gun nuts.
We just met on the tarmac out there.
I've seen it.
A restaurant,
please check your gun in Arizona.
They had like a fucking wall where you
check your guns in some Wyatt earp type
shit.
You know you got any guns?
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
I've got a few of those nine
millimeters.
Yeah,
that's the gunman.
Nine millimeters.
Why do you like them?
Just like the shape,
the sound,
the bullet,
everything about it,
man.
It's.
And it's not too big.
It's not too small.
Know it just fires.
As far as handguns go,
it's very easy gun to shoot at.
I have a glock nine millimeter shoots
like it's.
It doesn't like.
No,
it doesn't.
Like I have a rifle,
the seven millimeter remington ultra
mag.
I have a 300 win mag,
two big kicking fucking elephant killing
guns.
Bone digs into your shoulder like this.
It just is such a difference between a
rifle and a pistol.
Pistols like feel so small.
Like I feel like like if you were
hunting with a rifle,
like sometimes people hunt with pistols.
If you're hunting with a rifle and you
hit something that thing's dead.
If you you're hunting with a pistol and
he hit something like,
Ooh,
they might survive the shoot.
An elk with a nine millimeter and my
runaway hooker guns,
they keep in their bra.
You ever.
I love the Desert Eagle.
50 caliber.
Ridiculous gun you ever will see the
footage girls shooting the Desert Eagle.
That is so good.
Boom,
right into her hand was one,
two or girls shooting and her,
her tits are exploding like as she
shooting like the recoils like boom or
taste like sugar.
But yeah,
I've seen the girl hit herself in the
head guy that video.
There's videos that late night.
You'll just get on and just start
fucking laughing your head off.
That person's rude.
Whoever gave that girl that gun.
What the fuck was going to happen in
your hand?
It's a canon.
We shot one of those.
Remember Brian when we filmed my comedy
special down in Tempe in 2005,
we went to the,
uh,
what was it like the Phoenix
gun club or someplace?
Gun Club?
Wherever they.
Yeah,
we shot everything.
Machine guns.
We Shot Desert Eagles.
Oh,
44 mag dms.
We search out these ridiculous pistols.
They throw your hand back.
You literally can't hold it straight.
You can't know.
And the fire that comes out of it is
unbelievable.
I grew up in the bay area and I just
love dirty Harry.
I loved it.
I loved those films and I just loved him
just to Canon like he represented a
weird part of San Francisco and that
wasn't represented anywhere else in the
world.
Everybody has thought about San
Francisco.
They thought about gay people.
That was it.
San Francisco was gay people and hippies
and all of a sudden,
wait a minute,
what is this guy doing here?
And he was a northern California guy.
I mean he was mayor of Carmel.
Yeah,
I know,
right?
Even nuts.
Yeah.
Unbelievable runs for mayor wins.
Marries the local news caster.
He did?
Yeah.
The chick was.
They recently got divorced as like all
kinds of evil going on.
Who's evil going on?
My kid can't catch a break.
Just add to what a what a God.
The secret was he was gay the whole
time.
Dirty Harry was actually gay.
Yeah.
It was like overcompensating big black
guy.
That's what dirty Harry was really all
about.
It was all about him.
Fighting against is homosexual.
Urgent.
Sorry.
Kill.
Lucky.
It was a different sort of.
Because like San Francisco was never
thought of as being like a crime
fighting town at all.
You know,
you think in New York,
New York is where all the cop shows
where you have a movie like that in San
Francisco.
It was cool.
That guy that was in the first one,
he.
He plays the a sniper.
He's the dude
from the warriors come out
that guy.
Tough Gig for a dude to be that like a
character actor,
psycho guy.
Just be once you're a psycho guide,
the fucking leading man roles and no
longer available to you.
You're a psycho.
God.
Take the psycho role says it great.
You know what I mean?
Like I've done a few movies and I'm
always like,
when?
When do I get to kill a guy?
You know?
I always get killed.
It's,
you have a weird path in a comedy man.
I think that's weird.
The weirdest path I've ever heard of
being 44 years old and starting standup.
Yeah.
You had a must.
You must have been fucking running like
you must have hit the ground running.
I never stopped.
He kind of had to because like if you're
going to really do this,
like not a lot of time for people to
accept it right now if you're 53 and
they're like,
oh,
he's been doing comedy for eight years,
people go,
oh,
all right.
Yeah,
but if you're 53 and he just started
yelling,
Woo,
boy,
you're on your way to 60 before your
seven years in La.
It's pretty wild,
you know,
but I'll tell you what,
it saved my life.
Uh,
I was pretty,
you know,
when you're 44,
your friends are long gone.
Married with kids.
Cue The music.
Piano,
music.
It's true though.
Oh,
I know what you mean.
Like in your hold out,
like you didn't get married.
No family.
Right?
Right.
So you,
did you wonder about that,
about family?
Did you wonder what it was like?
No,
I had one great girlfriend lost her
because of rock and roll and she raised
the bar too high.
What was the bar like?
Just I'm saying she was a great
girlfriend,
like seven years of rock and roll.
Yeah.
Just,
you know,
just rock.
Just rock.
Because the one that got away.
Yeah,
she is the one that got check in with
her every now and again.
I tried it.
She doesn't have anything for it.
I did Davies Symphony Hall two weeks ago
in San Fran with Marin and I was like,
come down to the shell and just nothing
to no man,
but I know she got.
Nah,
she doesn't.
She never got married either.
Maybe I raised her par.
Maybe you did.
Maybe you just need to get together with
her.
Maybe I've tried it with a bow tie and a
bouquet of flowers.
Ty.
Come on like a wacky weather guy.
You know what I love.
What I do better though is like I did
some movies and stuff and she didn't go
like,
oh,
he must be getting famous.
I'm getting back.
You know what I mean?
She didn't do that.
That was cool.
Let's be honest.
We really didn't get famous but a person
that's normal
did.
You really did.
Maybe then she would,
you know,
maybe then to like,
hmm.
Uh,
okay,
one more chance.
But if you sell us out for rock and roll
again,
what was it about rock and roll?
It was just the hours being on the road.
Yeah,
it's that.
It's.
It's just like comedy.
I could never have a girlfriend now it's
I,
I dedicate myself 100 percent.
I'm out seven nights a week.
I don't miss a night.
I can't wait.
Am I going to do.
Unless they're in the Biz and work and
then we can hang during the day.
Yeah.
It's hard for people to win.
The worst thing is when a guy's talented
comic and he gets a girlfriend and she
doesn't like the lifestyle,
and then he shifts.
I seen it.
I've seen it happen too.
And then you run into those guys 10
years later when the girl had broken up,
but they want to try all over again.
It's ugly.
It's like,
dude,
you missed.
You missed the whole thing.
Like you're not a pro.
Now you try to.
You do you want to become a pro again?
Me had you had a chance at one point in
time,
but now you're fucked.
Yeah.
I never wanted to hear this.
Are you going to go out and again
tonight?
So I get every night,
you know?
Yeah.
And the ceiling,
especially at 44 starting when you
really got to commit,
you've got to hit the ground running.
You can't take a few slow years and half
asset and kind of get back in.
No Way,
man.
Once I started I was like,
Whoa,
this is hard.
Was it scary being 44 and like beginning
a new chapter in your life like that?
Or was it exciting?
It was.
It wasn't scary as far.
I loved it.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm back on stage.
Oh Shit.
And I'm doing this,
but the survival mode is brutal.
You know,
it costs a fortune.
I'm 40,
$49,
what am I going to do?
Live with nine dudes,
you know?
Hey,
my rent's 300 p like the older brother
that gives advice to the young crazy
kids.
This is not how you do ketamine boys.
You gotta be careful.
You can't intramuscularly shoot without
having alcohol on hand.
Don't know what the fuck you're doing.
This isn't sterile.
Yeah,
you know it,
it's just,
I just didn't think it was going to be
a,
I was going to work this hard,
like,
you know,
I was like,
Oh fuck,
I'm working hard,
you know.
Well,
what did you think?
You think it would be easy?
It did it look easy from the outside,
like you seen people crack jokes.
I never thought it was going to be easy
ever,
but I didn't think it was going to grab
me like it did.
I thought,
Oh yeah,
I'll go down and try it.
And then I started doing it and it
grabbed me and it took over my life in a
good way and I was like,
wow man.
I mean I literally work all day every
day.
I don't take a day off.
What do you mean by all day?
Everyday?
Like what do you do?
Well,
I podcast five days a week,
five days a week while I grabbed guests,
want home and bank them.
And then I,
uh,
I'm always auditioning.
Then I write all,
all day,
like from the sets.
I listened to the sets and I take notes
and then I go,
right now I'm,
I'm cohost and Tom Green's TV show when
he's on the road,
I guess tell us.
So there's no days off at none.
How did you,
uh,
when did you start doing this?
Tom?
Green thing I love is that he's doing it
still out of his house,
right?
Oh,
he moved it.
He got a warehouse,
uh,
in,
in the valley and took all that stuff
and moved it to his house and it's about
a month old.
I've been doing it for about a month now
and it's so great man,
because it's a TV show and so he does it
on a regular basis.
So you have to guest host.
It's sorta like when Johnny Carson has
the same thing,
he goes on the road and then a producer
sometimes got three guys.
Yeah,
it's great.
And I,
I've had some really cool guests.
Had Mike Beach who's been an actor for a
35 years.
He was on sunset marquis for six
seasons.
He played Tio,
the black gang leader of a grim.
A bastards is also an er.
Had him on,
at Madonna's guitar player,
they just slept for tour,
a Monte Pittman on and uh,
and then I had a guy Shawn Carrigan from
a young and the restless,
so I have different kinds of guests and
it's cool.
And then we'd take skype calls and uh,
and regular calls.
It's when I first did tom shows like
when the first time Brian and I had
thought about doing something and then
when he had that set up in living room
where he was like,
it was crazy.
He had his own server room with all
these server set up and these crazy
fucking lines.
And we were trying to figure out like,
like Brian,
first of all,
one of the thing for Brunswick,
you don't need all of this.
Essentially.
He was like his own aol.
We were like,
what is going on here?
It seems like.
Yeah.
And they were doing it with a company
out of Denver,
you remember?
And the company out of Denver wanted to
do something with me and we talked about
it,
but I was like,
wait a minute,
what?
What exactly are you doing?
Like,
how are you doing this like this and
that's why we started fucking around
with Justin Dot TV too.
And uh,
we had thought about doing some other
sort of streaming version of one of
these things,
but Tom Green had gone balls out from
the jump.
It was a TV show in his house and his
house,
his whole house,
this house was abandoned essentially.
He just had a kitchen and a bedroom hit
a giant server room.
He had these wires all throughout the
middle of his house.
He's fat fucking cables that were laid
down everywhere.
You have to step over them.
So he's got all that stuff.
I love Tom Green because he represents
what I've have.
He's like,
you,
he's a self made,
you know what I mean?
Like he doesn't wait for people to come
to him.
He just does it since he was like 16,
you know,
he had a show on public access and
Canada.
Then he lands on MTV.
Then he starts doing his own show,
you know,
it's like pre jack ass and shit.
Well he's at his best to when he's doing
his own thing.
And when I think his,
his career experience like a wall,
it was because he was doing a bunch of
other people's Shit.
He was doing movies he was doing.
And you,
when you start doing that,
you get involved with all these
different producers and different
network people and different executives
and different people have different idea
of how your thing should go because
they're investing money in it and they
have say they can green light things are
shut things down and you can't have a
guy like that land to that kind of
constraints because you're never going
to get a Tom Green.
Yeah.
You get the Tom Green that showed up on
MTV,
the Tom Green that was doing that cable
access show.
These just a maniac.
Just let that guy beat that.
Yeah,
totally.
Totally.
And that's what he does.
And a lot of people,
they way they're like,
I hear this a lot.
They go,
yeah,
I got no agent or manager.
It's like,
get me either.
You just fucking go do it.
Man.
In this day and age is less less
important than it's ever been.
Totally less important than it's ever
been is changing on a daily basis.
On a daily basis.
You're getting more and more of these
social media apps.
That's us.
Bam.
That's cool.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
that was,
we were sitting in this place where
we're like,
this is cool.
This whole thing is pretty,
pretty dope.
You could drink.
Were taking calls.
I was like,
ah,
I love it.
He had all those pencils.
I don't know why
I've got it.
Set Net.
Dean del Ray.
Look at it now,
man.
It's crazy.
Is it different?
Oh yeah.
Last same place.
Uh,
he moved,
he got a warehouse.
He moved all the stuff
out of his house because he was just
like,
I can't have these people in my house
anymore.
So chuck is set up now.
It's unbelievable.
He's also been doing a lot of
periscoping.
Him and Andy Dick.
I mean Andy Dick Pretty much lives on
periscope now.
It's really weird seeing them on it.
But we ran into him the other day at the
comedy store,
periscoping,
periscope at each other.
I was periscoping him,
periscope and me double what I meant
tonight as it the same set that he just
moved to a warehouse and this.
Check it out.
There it is.
Look,
so he's got.
Just fast forward a little bit.
This is supposed to be him.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but look,
man,
it's a story.
Eric Griffin.
I know the dude.
It's a straight up talk show inside a
full warehouse.
Here's,
here's the problem with that is the
worst dumb fucking way to sit down when
you're talking to somebody.
Why are you above him?
Yeah.
Know Eric's taller than you.
And second of all,
why?
Why would you sit like that while he
sits sideways?
I.
that's so retarded.
Podcasts on the way to talk.
This is good.
You look at me.
We're right here.
There's not one person like people got
mad at me when I had this special
ergonomic chair.
It was like taller,
so I got all these tweets like trying to
psychologically have an up try to
psychologically be above your gross.
I'm way taller than you have to be
above.
You'd look down upon you.
Letterman's a tall dude anyway,
and then on top of that,
his desk is tall.
Yeah,
he's very tall.
Oh yeah.
And on top of that,
his desk is taller.
That's odd approach,
but that's how everybody always did it.
Was that sideways desk,
the Johnny Carson style desk.
Why?
What did,
what are you writing books?
What's the desk?
Why do you have a fucking desk to talk
to people?
You need a desk that seems retarded,
but it's like the guy was a school
teacher or something.
I mean that's how we looked at it.
A fucking desk and everyone's so on.
Original people are just such copycats
that everybody.
Craig Ferguson,
everybody,
Jimmy Kimmel,
everybody just copies the original
Johnny Carson up,
which is one of the worst formats that
were for communicating with people.
The only thing it does is establish that
one person is in control of the
situation.
The Guy Behind the desk,
that's the captain,
and so you'll be right back.
You know,
he could be right back quicker than if
just like all bunch of dudes sitting
around a circle with the chairs the same
height and in the same style.
And just then it'd be a little weird,
like,
why is Dean that the head?
Why doesn't Tom Green get to decide when
they go?
You know what I mean?
That's why I think Joan rivers had it
best.
She had it in bed,
which is the most comfortable.
Or just gazing each other's eyes.
May touch some feet.
Amanda.
I didn't get a chance to do that right
now.
I'm going to add that I really didn't
get a chance to meet her either,
but I.
Bummer.
I was booked on that.
I was booked on that and something
happened.
We canceled or some,
someone canceled.
I don't remember the exact details,
but she was an all time great.
Oh God.
All the time.
Great.
Ballsy to the end.
I mean,
just that what she had to put up with
when she decided to run show after
carson and he just bands
her.
She could have easily just been buried.
You know,
son was a douchebag.
Oh,
you watch the documentary.
He had a big dude and he was a big Dick.
Both things were different than,
man,
you can't be that guy today.
Nobody would allow it.
It would get out that you're that kind
of a con shitty to people,
but it's also back then you know we
talked about this with Howard stern and
radio guys is like back then they were
all fighting over a time slot and that's
kind of stupid
time slots are gone now.
It's people whenever they're working and
listening or working out or commuting or
whatever.
Well because of dvrs and also with
these,
one of the things that letterman kind
of,
one of the reasons why he decided to
step back was what shows had become
mostly is like the show would get a
certain amount of views but would really
would get a lot of use,
would be the clips from the show that
would go online and then people will be
able to access those whenever they
wanted it and that became a big thing
and he was missing that.
He was like,
we're not doing that.
Like Jimmy Fallon is doing that Kimmel's
doing that.
We're not doing that anymore.
And he just realized that that the whole
genre was kind of passing his style by.
Yeah.
They're like,
Marin was on last week and they made the
quip that Marin stops masturbating
because it drought because he
masturbates in shower and it was a huge
clip on youtube.
You're instantly going to watch it,
you know,
because uh,
they break it down into the,
the meat of the interviews,
the funny jokes where you can watch the
show kind of in like 15 minutes.
Yeah.
Like that Louis ck thing.
Everything is great and no one's happy.
No.
The thing about a technology that was on
Conan and that became like this huge
viral sensation which was way bigger hit
than the actual episode itself,
which,
you know,
not that many people watch conan
anymore.
Yeah,
it's pretty low,
right?
It's very low in comparison to like what
the Johnny Carson show used to be at one
point in time.
There's no show like that where
everybody watches the tonight show,
a million a night,
Carson.
And then I guess when he signed off $60
million on the 97.
Yeah.
When you get on the tonight show back
then they made a star out of you.
There's no show like that anymore.
That makes someone a star,
but if you became a regular in the
tonight show and he would sit on the
couch next to Johnny,
you were in man.
You made it.
You were royalty.
You were.
You were adorned,
you were knighted.
Yeah.
Steven,
right.
I mean it changed his world.
Was that Letterman or was that Carson?
Carson,
Carson.
He was asked back the next day because
we come back tomorrow and he came back,
did another set the next day or
whatever,
but
I.
I said this to people all the time.
It's,
it's bigger to do Rogan,
podcast or Marin or say the top five
than it is to do it tonight.
Show set.
Now it is.
Yeah,
because I go all over and people go,
man,
I heard you on such and such and it's
amazing because people find those
podcasts at different times.
If
you're on TV goes by and if they didn't
see it,
they didn't see it,
but everyday somebody finds an episode.
I was on a say this a year from now that
I just heard John Rogan man and they
discovered on their own timeframe.
Well we have it set up the most access
possible to.
I don't have a subscription based.
Some guys like you can get the first
episodes like Marin has that right?
Yeah,
the backlog,
first 50 or free or whatever,
and then you buy the backlogs.
But I feel like like you fuck yourself
when you do that.
I feel like the real connection is,
is the fact that it's all free.
That's a big.
That's the,
the,
the easiest.
He can get it.
Whether it's through stitcher or through
youtube or through ustream or Vimeo or
whatever the fuck it is.
You just gotta be able to get it as
easily as possible.
And then if people like it,
it just spreads the growth we're
experiencing because of just word of
mouth.
We're up 2 million downloads from last
month.
Wow.
10 million in a month.
I call it.
It's like an exponential fucking tsunami
of madness.
It's crazy.
I call it the,
uh,
it's like metallica.
It's the old school grassroots.
Metallica had a cassette tape,
like 40 people got them.
Lars sent them two guys.
I love Metallica.
Send me a tape.
They copied those tapes,
they send them to their buddies,
their buddies copy those tapes.
They send them in their bodies in a
matter of five years.
There's probably $200,000
of those cassettes out grass roots.
Tell me.
It's not ironic that Lars Ulrich wasn't
gonna to take down napster after all
that.
So Larry,
it's like word of mouth and the ability
to spread your shit was what made them
in the first place and then he's like,
hey man,
we want that money.
That money.
Napster should have used Trey Parker and
Matt Stone.
Instead.
They gave a vhs.
They made a vhs tape as a little
Christmas gift.
It was like a 10 minute thing and then
that spread through Hollywood over
night.
I saw it.
I saw it back then before the show was
on.
Yes,
I did.
That was the Brian Boitano one.
Oh my God.
It was God damn genius.
Well,
Brian Boitano do.
Alls I'm saying is metal people,
the way they spread stuff are like what?
Pod comedy podcasts people are.
It's great.
They're like,
man,
did you hear this show?
I think one of the best things about
comedy podcast is unlike what happened
with Johnny Carson and Joan rivers,
podcasts was all support other podcasts,
so it seems to be across the board.
I haven't seen any beef where podcasts
are saying,
hey,
if you do Adam Carolla show,
you can't do my show.
No one does that.
No,
that was the model.
That was the model.
They all did it.
They all did totally.
They all fucked each other because of
that and because they were fighting over
these time slots and everyone had this
famine theory going on where if you
weren't number one,
you were below number one and if you
were losing,
if you're in second place,
he made less money and everyone's
panicking so they had these politics are
playing back and forth like that.
Remember that movie that they is
correct.
Jay Leno,
David Letterman and the late night wars
and that.
Doesn't NBC do that right now with like
fallon or somebody like
that?
If you do found you can't do camel or
something,
you can do family.
They probably have laws like that.
You know,
they probably.
I mean,
some people could probably do whatever
the fuck they want,
but they probably have laws like that or
unwritten rules didn't.
There you go.
I do them all and they go,
that's fine.
We just want to narrow.
It's a stupid model.
You have to be tuned in by 11:00.
That's when it starts and it ends at
1:30.
Why?
Just show it all the time.
Have it available whenever anybody wants
to watch it,
then it will be better.
It's like this model of like tuning in
for something and waiting for it.
Like that's why I love Netflix.
Netflix takes a season and they go a
season.
Three of the orange is the new black is
out.
Good luck.
Then you get all the fucking episodes.
The whole season is out in one fell
swoop that benchwatch,
which I love to do in a hotel somewhere
on the road to best tap.
If you get ahold of a fucking series and
you find out about it and you find out
about it like after five seasons already
done.
Oh,
I didn't find out about game of thrones
until I think the second season.
So I watched the whole first season and
then deep and when I caught up I was sad
that we week.
That was me with breaking bad three
seasons straight.
I got the flu,
the flu.
It's still dark.
You're feeling shitty.
I watched all three and then I was like,
wait,
now I've got a wait.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
I think that that's the future is going
to be.
We're going to laugh one day thinking
about the idea of tuning into a special
time to watch a show like,
well not like a world premiere.
APM shouldn't ever eat your popcorn once
you've had it for hours uploaded,
uploaded.
So I can get it whenever on demand is
the future 100 percent.
Oh yeah.
Everything else is stupid.
It really is the idea of like tuning in,
like I guess maybe new shows with that
exception because the end of the day you
do want to kind of find him.
What the fuck is going on the world even
though shows man,
they're getting trounced by like the
young Turks and all these online shows
that can do whatever they want.
Well,
twitter,
as far as schools,
you find out news immediately.
Instantly.
Yeah.
Rip.
Someone will tag you.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
and just the think when periscope does
catch on more,
it's going to be news,
twitter,
but video.
So like if something's happening in
Washington,
we could just turn to that exact street
for people on periscope right there.
We've got four different camera views.
Totally right now and that's what it's
going to be like.
USTREAM did a lot of that during the
ferguson riots.
Streaming services that do that during
the during Baltimore.
All that kind of stuff is the future.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Periscope.
I mean that is definitely the future
man.
I was watching somebody last night for
an hour.
I had no idea who they were.
They were just as miscellaneous person
in Germany.
Just watching them hanging out,
which things that we were watching
the twitch channel which has all these
people playing video games and then
you'll,
you'll look down and say,
Whoa,
hold on.
That guy's got 10,000
people watching him play a video game.
That fucking arena filled with people
and you think about if you're performing
in front of 10,000
people,
you'd be like,
Holy Fuck,
you reach 10,000
people with your words.
That's crazy.
Right?
Guys playing a video game.
Did you read,
did you read that article,
Joe?
Um,
which has really hit me big time as a
comedian.
If you have 1000 true fans,
you can survive as an artist.
What does that,
what are you showing me?
I was just showing that the other day on
periscope at 10,000
live viewers.
You had 10,000
people watching live on periscope live
at the same time.
I don't know if it's all the same time,
but it was 10,000
different people watch and it was just
fucking with people.
I'm like,
wait,
I'm sorry,
what are you saying?
If you have a thousand true fans,
what?
Yeah,
yeah,
there's a,
there's an article a guy wrote,
I read it online about two weeks ago and
he said that if you as an artist have
1000 true fans,
you could survive a doing art,
whatever form of art you do forever.
Because he said the 1000 people,
which you think,
oh,
that sounds pretty easy.
I'm trying to get 100 right now.
This is an incredible article.
If you read this,
it doesn't matter.
Well,
we'll get to the end of the long.
The long tails of famously good.
What?
Okay.
Just stop.
I'm reading.
Fuck scrolling.
Fuck.
The long tail is famously good news for
two classes of people.
A few lucky aggregators such as Amazon
and Netflix and 6 billion consumers of
those two.
I think it's okay.
This is what they said though.
Basically as if you have 1000 fans that
each spend about $100 a year on your
meaning.
They bought a DVD,
you know,
or they bought a ticket,
a couple of tickets or they watched your
special 100 a year.
You got about 100,000
after everything,
maybe 50,
60.
You could survive.
Awesome.
On that.
Every year.
The problem I have is the term true fan,
right?
I fucking,
I don't even like saying fans either.
People who,
like you say friends,
people who like soldiers,
what you're doing.
I always say,
I always tell friends,
Maris,
I call them my friends because we're.
If they're in the stuff I'm.
We would be friends.
Yeah,
if you're doing good shit and people
like your good shit and they keep
supporting it.
When you have a commitment with them,
it's kind of cool because it's like you
have customers.
It's like say if you were like a guy who
made great shoes or something and about
handmade shoes,
you've got a bunch of customers that
swear by the Dean del Rey shoe and they
buy them whenever they can and it's like
if you're doing good work and there they
appreciate good work.
If you really can nail it and just lock
it as a comic,
it's a.
it's hard.
Right?
It makes you feel good though.
Like they liked my podcast.
I get emails at night,
man,
and they're like,
dude,
the stuff
you're talking about with music,
no one likes it.
Like me,
I feel.
And your,
you know,
they like I can relate man and it's,
it feels good.
Let there be taught.
Because your product,
is it mostly about rock and roll or is
it all kinds of shit?
It's all kinds of shit,
but I really a,
I have a lot of rock and rollers on and
people that I loved in life that have a
dna that influenced me,
you know,
I try to seek them out.
Maybe a guy that built choppers,
you know,
like a or a guy who.
An amazing motor builder and then a
comedian that blows my mind then a
rocker.
And if you have the cool thing about
what you're doing is you don't have to
talk to anybody about what you do.
You don't have to like sit down with
some guys.
Go Dean,
I think we're in the wrong direction
with this.
What we want to do is,
first of all,
I want to dye your mustache mustache.
The young kids today,
they can't relate.
They,
you know,
the tattoos are great.
But uh,
maybe a lip ring.
Yeah.
They're trying to like get you hip.
Maybe a teardrop tattoo.
Just a little one in the corner.
And I look at dudes like you and Marin
and,
and those are the dudes and burt and I,
just,
those are the guys,
you know,
if you,
if you like something,
you know,
you figure it out.
Like these guys are doing it,
man,
you know,
they're doing it and you figure out
like,
what is my niche?
I love music.
Let's talk about rock.
But I love comedy too.
So we got guys on,
you know,
being yourself,
being in yourself.
That's the cool thing about podcasts.
You can really truly be yourself because
you just have a microphone and a camera
on you.
You don't even have a camera.
You just do.
It's just audio,
right?
Audio.
Yeah.
That,
that's just never.
There's never been a time where you
could do that.
There's never been a time we could have
your own fucking radio show.
It's available instantly.
If I drive home right now,
I can go into itunes or go into the
podcast app or either on my iphone and I
just write Dean del Rey and it'll show
me the therapy.
We talk,
boom.
And I'll just start streaming it.
I'll put my foot down,
I put my seat,
my phone down on a seat at a red light.
During that red light.
I picked up your podcast and I'm
listening to it now.
That's insane.
Or I could say it.
I mean those fucking who say Dean del
Rey and they'll put it up in a search.
It's amazing how accurate that thing.
It's crazy.
What's a weird time to be alive with the
whole shit?
I was.
I was lucky too that I figured out how
to do it on my own.
You know,
like I was looking at Brian.
I went on the road with Brian last year
and this fucking guy works his ass off.
We're out on the road.
How dare you lie to America knows him
way more than you did when we were out
on the road.
He was working his ass off.
He had the shows booked.
He had the hotel's booked,
he had the car rental car,
he had the flights and we're cruising
around and I was like,
is a self made,
you know,
machine here,
the desk squad.
You have to figure out a way to do your
own in this day and age
because if you,
if you do bring other people in,
especially in the beginning,
you're going to have to give them a cut
of almost nothing.
So like as you're hustling and you're
trying to put together these shows,
if you're given a manager 15 percent of
that or an agent,
10 percent,
25 percent is gone.
Then you have to pay taxes.
Yeah.
Anyway,
it sucks is when you're on the road with
somebody,
it does have a manager and then they
still get your 10 percent.
Like,
I don't want to say who,
but like I like got checks because I was
on the road and their manager took my.
Took 10 percent of the mic and I'm like,
wait,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
When we talk a lot,
you got robbed.
You don't have a contract with someone.
And they took 10 percent of your check.
Who the fuck is this?
Nothing.
Fuck did that.
Somebody robbed.
I know that.
So it's weird,
but I can tell you that it's going to
get a certain amount and then they took
them out.
Brian opened up the can.
Someone's robbing?
No,
not that I know,
but uh,
but with working with like Dean
[inaudible],
the Dean doesn't have it.
Let's have a fake name.
Let's use a fake name.
Rhymes with.
Fuck man,
that's gross.
That's someone's stealing money.
That's,
you know,
it's just weird that managers even do
that.
So damaging you.
If he's not managing judging
you like a manager,
here's a person that Gig.
Where's your cut as well?
Well,
here's the deal though.
What is this?
What I'm saying is,
as a manager,
a manager is a longterm commitment.
I've had the same manager since I was an
open mic or most comedians try to keep
it manager for a long time and the agent
is someone who works with you guys but
is not as close as the manager.
The manager's supposed to be the person
that's like looking over your career in
an advisory position and like no one's
advising you because not advising you go
on periscope now.
I really think it'll help because he's
not advising you at all.
She's taking 10 percent.
For what reason?
Say stuck in a Gig.
I guess you got to get that money back.
Dude.
Take time.
We're going to find that money back.
One way or another.
We had a book,
a Gig with this guy and then we'll go
steal.
Steal that money.
Damn it.
Sorry.
Jacob Dylan loves you,
man.
I wanted to tell you that he still
remembers the time.
His kids got to go down to the set of
fear factor.
He never forgot it.
He was like,
man,
it was so great.
My kids just lost their minds.
They were in there.
The guy's eating eyeballs,
you know,
five feet away.
And He loved it.
Man.
He's a good guy.
He is a great piece of really,
really fucking talent singer too.
It's just some of my best friends.
Is He really?
I always wondered why they didn't like
take off like those.
What was that song?
I can remember when one headline that,
well they sold.
They sold 26 million records.
I know,
but wow.
How come you didn't keep making jams
like that?
Like what happened?
Well,
when you have a record
that fucking big,
it was huge.
That is hard to come.
You know,
people.
You're wearing an ACDC hats.
So shut your mouth.
Shit for me.
Come on man.
I'm just saying it is hard though.
Like some people you know.
Here's the example.
Deeds.
Come on,
he's giving you.
I love that.
Yeah.
Want to graduate but not this way.
Here's what you gotta do.
Get that rock and roll voice.
What is that?
Oh my God,
I forgot about that shit.
Stand up so that they can see on the
camera.
Wow.
Who did that?
Man?
Oh,
this guy.
Oh yeah,
that's bad ass guy named Nikko Hurtado.
California guy.
Yeah,
he worked.
He worked on a Kat von D on that TV show
a couple of years,
but he has his own place out in grass
valley and this guy is next level for
portraits.
He super talented for everything.
Super fucking talented.
So good man.
I went out there 16 hours.
That thing ate and ate.
That took 16 hours.
And this,
this rib cage is the worst place ever to
get a tattoo.
I'm already started.
I went,
hey,
you might want to move to another spot
for a few minutes.
That's kind of tender.
And he's like,
yeah,
the whole thing's going to be like that
as like what?
We're only 10 minutes.
You're ready to quit?
Oh yeah.
I will make it a bumblebee.
And how much harder is it than your
arms?
It's so.
It's,
it's like I can't describe it.
it's so bad.
It's so bad that I didn't get angus on
the other side,
which was the original plan.
I,
I'll probably do it though if you do it,
we should film it on periscope,
right?
Actually,
we should have him do it here in the
studio with Joey Diaz is getting
sponsors on periscope now.
There's,
they're contacting him because he does.
He does the morning joint,
gets up in the morning.
He lights up a joint and he starts
dropping science of motivation.
Dog.
Good.
So for,
you know,
whatever minutes he,
when he gets up and smokes his first
joint of the day,
he brings people on this ride with them.
They call it the morning joint.
So he's going to get.
You could get a sponsor.
You had your tattoo.
That'd be great.
Right?
It might have been paid for the Tattoo
man about that.
I really want to get the other side done
and I want to get the comedy star Logo.
Yeah.
It's just I needed a new logo a little.
No,
no,
no.
I love.
It was just a big deal to me though.
You know what I mean.
My name's on the wall and it was just
like it was,
it was the biggest thing that ever
happened to me and I played music and
toured with everybody and done all kinds
of shit,
but that was next level stuff.
It's great until you look at some other
people to run them
wall on fucking second split Gaddy boys.
What fucks on that?
We'll take some black paint.
I sat there the other day and just
googled like half the names on the front
patio because I was like,
what?
What's a z cat like,
what is Zika?
And half of them I don't even think are
real.
I think literally people like came in
there and just know there's a few,
like a towing truck company isn't on
there.
Like how was it?
Totally.
Yeah.
I'll show it to you.
It's weird.
It's pretty.
It's it,
it's a big deal.
To me though.
It's just like from the ground up,
I was 44.
I just stumbled onto that patio like,
Hey,
I'm here to do comedy and they're like
get the fuck outta here.
Don't had fitzsimmons on yesterday.
And we were talking about that book
about the comedy store.
What is it called?
What is it?
Grow to a comment you don't know
standing there or what is it a.
what's it called?
It's great book,
man.
I can't believe no one's made that
movie,
but what he was basically saying was
that at those days,
what I'm dying up here,
he was saying that at the description of
what the store was in the seventies is
exactly like it was today.
Yeah.
Like it was like common hanging out in
the back patio.
People going on stage there.
It's amazing.
That place is kept that freaky vibe.
I did a dollar show last night,
the doormen show and the in the belly
room on such a good idea for a show to
you don't understand how happy it makes
all the like the door guys and stuff
that worked there because they pretty
much used to have two nights of open mic
and then they took it away.
It's way better for,
for the people that work there because
that was the only reason why these guys
work their work their spot.
So the doormen went up,
Jeff Ross did some time and I closed it
out.
I did a half an hour and close it out.
It's all sold out.
It's only a buck is so cool right there
in that room.
Own it.
Says it says capacity 57.
Yeah.
Fire Marshal.
I think they might vary a little bit
over.
I don't know what they actually get in
there,
but it's probably about 94 during a show
there next week.
Where you do it with us.
If I'm around warranties doing my
podcast next week,
it's like June 17th.
Um,
we're doing on a Wednesday night and I
podcast and comedy show in there.
If we had you,
it'd be the three of us.
It'd be insane.
And red bands on Florentines on the
15th.
So you're doing it on the 17th at 10?
Yeah,
if I can that,
I'd love it man.
That'd be so fun.
New Material.
Show the new material shot earlier.
Yeah.
And then we're right after.
Okay.
I'll do it.
I think it is.
I'm there then.
Definitely be so great.
That room is just so amazing.
It's magic,
right?
I started in there and I just ruined the
country.
I just,
you know,
dice did a special in there.
He did that first record in there.
Right?
And the o arm,
that's what I heard,
right?
No.
Yeah,
I think so.
Which one?
Uh,
the very first one that,
the one that just says dice.
Yeah,
he did that in the belly.
That's not good enough.
I'm looking it up right now.
Try doing.
What was the story that you told on
podcast about Joe Walsh?
Bill Walsh.
Unbelievable story.
Joe Walsh is first of all an APP.
Absolute King.
Like,
let me tell you,
he's one of the nicest guys I've ever
opened for a.
he's like,
so cool.
You think it'd be Joe Walsh?
I can't.
I'm in the eagles.
Who the fuck are those?
It wasn't like that at all,
but we're eating a,
a deli tray and he comes into the
dressing room and he says,
hey,
don't eat that shit.
And we're like,
what?
Why?
And he goes,
ah,
you don't know what's in there man,
you know,
it's just a Shitty Deli tray.
Don't eat it.
He's all.
I got sick before.
And I was like,
Oh really?
And he goes,
yeah,
let me tell you.
He gets,
after he was out of the eagles,
he had a real low spot where he was
partying hard and canceling gigs all the
time.
So he cleaned up and the manager said,
we're book a tour,
but if you cancel one show,
all the shows will be gone.
So the first night of the tour,
he's backstage eating on the deli tray
after sound check and about a couple of
hours later he gets mad food poisoning
and he starts just shitting and shitting
and he's like,
what am I going to cancel on?
The manager goes,
you cancel this Gig.
The entire tour is gone.
So they go to Kmart or whatever was open
and they get the rubber fishing waders.
He puts them on the ones that go up to
your tits.
The river runs through it,
fly fishing.
He gets on stage and just start going at
it.
Why are you shitting?
Like every couple,
like every few minutes is.
Oh,
oh yeah.
Shitting into rubber letters.
Then he said mid show.
He didn't expect
this,
but the heat from the lamp started
burning the
diarrhea acid on his legs.
So I looked at it.
Joe Walsh,
we're wearing those because he wore
weird shit all the time.
Shitting himself with weirs on first for
him though.
First Minute I met him.
That's the story.
Tell me,
and I hope it's true.
It's so great.
It's amazing.
What a great story.
I love the eagles,
man.
No,
the eagles or rocky mountain high rocky
mountain way is one of my favorite songs
ever.
Oh,
I love that song.
I love it.
He a shoes,
bom,
Bom,
bom.
What you're going to do to not their
Mama,
you know,
he uh,
he wrote that one on long run.
It's great.
Life's been good to me so far.
Oh,
great.
Fucking sign.
And it's also one of those songs about a
guy talking about like,
you know what,
I'm just going to keep doing this.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm living retarded rock and roll life.
I got arrested.
I'm doing stupid shit,
but life's been good to me so far.
That's my theme song,
man.
He's in the fucking eagles,
you know all the legendary bands.
And that was the one that was featured
in the big Lebowski.
Dude.
Hey man,
it fucking eagles.
Eagles never been offended going,
how could you hit the Eagle's hotel?
California the fuck.
Do you hate Hotel California?
I that record is so good,
so much good.
All their shit victim.
The love the eagles documentary,
right?
Victim of love.
It's fucking bananas.
That's great.
That's a serious fucking song.
Desperado.
The shit is great.
Those guys are legends,
man.
Just handfuls of songs.
Yeah,
they had some great writing to,
but Hotel California is one of the all
time great songs.
It really is.
I love it.
That in life in the fast lane man,
man,
they had some amazing,
amazing fucking songs.
What happened with those guys?
They didn't get along.
They broke up and they got back together
again when they realized how much money
was involved in.
I remember they did the hell.
They said,
we'll get back together when hell
freezes over.
And then in [inaudible] 96,
I think it was,
it's called the hell freezes over to.
I was glad because I never got to see
him and they opened.
I saw him at the shoreline and the bear
and they opened with Hotel California.
Can you even fucking you opening Hotel
California?
Man Her in for a great concert.
You Lion Eyes.
That's a great fucking great man.
Great one,
I really liked the long run record.
A lot of people don't like it.
It's the last one before they broke up.
It's just pure cocaine,
but man,
that's good songs on it.
I'm already gone.
Yeah,
already already gone.
Already gone is a great fucking song.
Yeah,
if they had some jams they did,
man.
Those were some driving songs to be in
your car and those come on and go,
fuck yeah,
I love that.
Those guys,
they had three voices.
That's what's a great band.
You got,
you got,
you know Glen Fry who added cool hit on
Miami,
vice member smuggler's blues.
That's a great one thing.
You Have Joe Walsh sings and then you
have Don Henley sinks and then even the
Bass player sings that one can tell you
what song.
Yeah,
that guy's great,
man.
Great Song.
Wow,
that's right.
That's eagles to jam.
So many hits gets those.
That era,
man,
there was so much good music out of that
era.
It's weird how music comes big waves
like that.
I guess comedy does too right now.
It's a huge wave.
This is probably the biggest waves I've
ever seen.
Yeah.
Comedy wise,
I think this is the biggest way that
we've ever seen.
We were talking about that the other
night at the store.
We were like this,
the golden era of comedy and everybody
agreed like at all.
Like Sarah Silverman was onstage kill
and I was hanging out with burr.
We were in the backstage.
We're talking about comedy today and
this bird just got back from like 18.
Sold out shows.
Just crap.
That show.
It was crazy amazing,
but we were talking about it.
We're like,
is this.
Has there ever been a better time for
standup then right now?
And we were all like,
just not.
There's no better.
I don't think there's ever been a better
time with like more like big name
headliners and more young guys coming up
like the store.
I've been around the store.
I took a seven year break,
but I started there in [inaudible] 94.
I never saw crop of hungry,
dedicated new guys.
Like now it's like there's always a few
guys that were okay and I would like
find those guys and try to help them
would grab them,
like,
look,
you could stay alive,
but you got to keep moving,
you know,
but now it's like they have their own
ecosystem.
It's a totally different thing.
There's way more power like that,
that having that roast battle and all
these different,
like these bonding shows,
they have these bonding shows,
you know?
Absolutely.
They're creating a complete environment
of art.
Man.
You know,
it's like there's no one around going,
sorry man,
you look like this or that,
or you're too old or too young.
It's like,
Hey,
we're all here and we're creating this.
Well that say that they're always the
problem.
People that you're too young,
you're too old,
you're too this.
You're too,
that you're too tall,
you're too short.
You those people.
Always wrong.
Because guys like Joey Diaz just exist.
They don't.
You can't ever script that.
You can't hope for that to walk through
your door.
You can't turn a guy into that does.
That is what it is.
And he's the funniest guy.
If this is the funniest time for comedy,
I think it is.
I think d is the funniest guy that's
ever lived.
I really do.
I don't think there's ever been any
funnier.
I seen kinison live.
I've seen Hicks live.
I seen what I saw prior live.
It was already really late in his life,
but no one is ever crushed in front of
me.
Like,
like Joey Diaz has.
The other night he did the comedy story,
did the or and I had a post about it on
instagram.
I was like,
you just broke the world.
It was insane.
People were falling out of their chairs.
It was screening.
People were screaming,
laughing,
screaming.
And the great thing though is that he
has a guy like you who shouts it out
that that's not like,
well,
this is my world,
you know,
like the old world where people would be
like,
or this is all me and I'm not letting
anybody else in.
Yeah.
Well those.
There's always a group of people.
Back then when they had to be,
everybody had to be the best.
That was like one guy had the be the
guy,
whether it was dice,
whether it was Kennison or was.
There was like,
there was always one guy that was the
best and he thought it was the best and
then he would have guys around him,
but those guys always sucked.
No,
they weren't that good.
Somebody called them satellite.
They weren't
that good,
but like Diaz is the funniest guy alive
now.
He's the funniest guy ever and he's the
guy I take with me on the road.
That's great.
Whenever I can,
whenever he's not busy,
but now it sucks because everybody knows
I can't take him with me anywhere.
He's always busy.
Sells out every.
He's just crushed.
Denver.
Just came in for NATO.
He hadn't been there.
He had been banned from that club
forever.
Wow.
I'm at nine in there at the end of the
month places the first time ever.
I love that.
Amazing.
That's where I filmed my last comedy
special on comedy central special.
I knew that when I went in and I was
like,
this is the one where you did your
special on a rocky mountain high.
Right,
and then I go in there and after the
first joke I drop in my head,
I got like edit that fucking rock cave
hits that.
The people are on the stage,
the places alive.
It's electric too.
Crazy little club,
crazy,
crazy little club,
but it's just this time man,
this is really unprecedented were all
comedians are supporting each other too.
It's not like that whole backstabbing
Johnny Carson type thing we were talking
about before.
He used to be like that with comedy too,
but sound like that anymore.
Everybody's like,
this is a great group of people
supporting each other.
Now I got lucky.
I didn't come in in the nineties,
you know,
I mean fun.
A lot of people already came in the
nineties.
Yeah,
but I'm just saying it was like there
wasn't much of a scene,
you know,
it was after that eighties gold rush.
Well that's when I came in.
I came in in [inaudible] 94.
That's when I arrived at the store.
It was the worst time ever.
Well,
the time when I came in,
when I first got there,
it was the worst era for the store ever.
Wow.
There was.
You would go there on a Monday or
Tuesday when he would see dog shit.
Wow.
Those guys were.
There was terrible comedy going on.
A bunch of them and the guy that ran it
was a fucking drunk and it was,
it was pre Tommy.
It was another guy read it.
This fucking thing was a disaster.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Oh God.
There were so many like leftovers that
should have made it from the eighties
but didn't.
And they fell apart.
They were still doing the same material,
but it was the.
You know how you get a few of those guys
that occasionally you'll see one of
those guys today.
It still has the same act for like
you'll be at the ha ha or giggles or
something like that.
It's crazy,
right?
You're like,
Whoa,
this guy doesn't have.
This is some old material.
Yeah.
Well that was what you've got in the
nineties,
but there were guys from the eighties
because it was a big wave in the
eighties.
The wave was like from 80,
early eighties to like late eighties and
then it started to die off into the
nineties.
The comedy clubs started closing.
The Boston scene collapsed like all
those evening at the Improv shows kind
of drifted away.
There was a bunch of those shows for a
while and then they slowly all faded
away and that was in the early nineties
and that's what I came around at the
leftovers.
Wow.
There was so much bad comedy and there
was a very few people.
There's no one from my era that started
off in [inaudible] 94.
That's around today.
Wow.
At the comedy store.
No one knowing that I could think of.
I can't think of one guy who was with me
back then who was in my state.
I was already headlining on the road and
I had a television show,
but realistically I've learned how to do
standing up at the store and that's bad
ass.
Realistically.
That's me too.
That's her.
I learned some jokes.
I knew a little bit about comedy,
but I learned.
I really learned that at the store that
are just.
And it changes all rules and it gets you
ready when you're out on the road.
You Go,
oh,
I seen this in the belly rooms.
The or compressed to a diamond valley
runs like a half of our half the alarm.
It's like,
this is a fort.
I call it a comedy for go upstairs.
You're in the fort,
you know,
and it just feels good and you're
looking at naked pictures to collapses.
Especially like those Roast Battle
Knights.
I don't even like going up there.
This is going to go in the kitchen.
Too many.
I mean not enough people in here.
It's great now with periscope though,
because all of us just sit and watch it
on periscope now.
It's got three feeds.
You got to be there though.
Do it because they're going to judge and
in a couple of weeks I can't wait.
You know what the problem with periscope
is though,
that some people that are outside of it
are not going to get it and they're
going to get angry.
Like at the whites only table.
Yeah.
And all the racism and the black wave.
There's like,
what did they call it?
The Negro waves?
Yeah.
My Boy Jeremiah Watkins is in that white
though.
He's allowed.
Yeah.
It's a whole thing is a.
it's.
It's a magic place and that killed Tony
too,
is a big part of that too.
Yeah.
You guys doing that podcast out there
and getting all these young people
giving them this one minute shot and it
made Kim and made sure Sarah.
No,
those,
those girls came out of that and now
they've got careers now things are
happening for that.
Well,
that's a good support group.
You know,
when you have a podcast and other people
in America are listening,
they get,
man,
I think I could try that,
you know?
Well I get these tweets all the time
from people.
Like they'll see the show that will put
together on the ice house or something
like that and they'd be like,
fuck,
I live in the wrong place.
Is Crazy.
You guys have these shows.
They're on a regular basis.
I know,
right?
The other night it was,
it was des.
I rera Brian Cowen,
me and Duncan.
Oh my.
It was just a fucking tornado hit.
That place is insane,
dude.
All those guys on their own make me
laugh.
So fucking hard man.
You know,
like Tom,
I rarely,
I,
I went on the road with him and man,
I just laughed my ass off the whole time
onstage,
offstage,
eating,
whatever,
you know,
it's just always great.
Like look at you and wanting to be on
the road with dom.
So,
so cool.
And he's been in it for ever,
like worries me with his drinking
though.
That's the only thing I worry about dom
is that he's getting older and he just,
he can't hit it hard every night.
Pop a Xanax
and keep.
When he first came on the podcast,
he was like all fucked up on the Xanax
you talked about.
Still takes them every night.
He takes one every day,
but he likes it for whatever reason,
you know,
I don't know.
Hey,
that is great man.
He's great.
An addiction.
Yeah.
I need to go back to cigarettes or
something.
The fuck are you talking about?
Why would you say that?
Mine's comments quit.
You just quit cigarettes for like four
days.
That's it,
and you're like,
I need to go back to cigarettes as if it
was a long time ago.
Back in the day,
working out,
going to pop up.
Of course he made a fort,
added five copies,
stirs up your toe.
You'll use as an excuse.
Fuck this,
I need a cigarette.
I stub my toe,
scuffed my new sneakers.
This bullshit need,
man.
He just got to need to.
You got a need to escape.
Then you've got to be really careful
about that because you're doing
something that's going to eventually
give you an illness and you know,
most likely one of those incurable ones
like lung cancer.
And if that happens,
dude,
you'll be thinking like Johnny Carson
was like Johnny Carson before he died,
would just walk around the house with an
oxygen mask and go those fucking
cigarettes and that's all he would say.
Those goddamn cigarettes.
I was fucking cigarettes.
I create a man.
It was brutal,
but it's like I was telling Brian,
I saw this guy,
he was 30 and he gets to hang out at
this bar.
I'd go to all the time,
one day showed up,
he goes,
yeah,
I'm going to be coming here for the rest
of my life.
And I go,
yeah,
I know you're here every day.
And he goes,
no,
I just got six months to live.
He got lung cancer,
but it was from a specialist or
something,
but he also smoked,
but I saw them whittle away in three
months.
He looked like Mr Burns from the
simpsons.
He had the oxygen thing and he came in
and I was like,
I'm off these men and I got the fuck off
him.
It scared me because he was just his 30
and dead know dead.
No,
no.
He died instantly and that was an I can
90 lung cancer's not cute.
It's gross.
Yeah.
Nina diction.
I mentioned I'm in a pill addiction but
that'd be good.
Xanax.
Uh,
I just,
I,
I just don't get why.
Like everyone I know is either on
adderall or Xanax.
They either have an up or down and you
talked to these people and they're like,
oh no,
I only like downers or I only like
uppers and it's,
it's everyone seems like they're on
something for some of the mistakes that
people are trying to solve.
Medical.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I've tried to go the full clean route
and be like,
just to see like my memory is fire right
now.
I quit caffeine.
My memory is incredible
because you quit caffeine so it was all
Kinda just drink like 10 coffees a day.
Then I'd be on stage and just be like
bird man.
Like sometimes they get a twitch up
here.
Too much caffeine.
Do you ever get that?
It's twitching here while you're
onstage.
Is that what that's from?
From caffeine
or sleep deprivation and it wind stop
and they'd be like,
God damn it.
My guys are doctors.
They're self diagnosing.
I'm getting canker sores from mentos and
this guy's getting twitches from coffee
for sure.
Definitely from the coffee fucking 25
years.
You were stuffing it through your
fucking nose.
Oh Man.
I've had some close calls on coke five
calls.
I had the numb arm in Marin,
had an MRI dated a bit about it,
but I was in Laurel Canyon.
I remember there was just the first time
I ever really saw pyramid a coke,
like people tried to do that because the
scarface,
you go to parties,
Nigga,
they had a pyramid of how many people
are stealing it.
Like putting them in touch with you
think.
Right.
But,
but like the people that are there,
they're just like,
yeah,
there's plenty of coke,
you know,
how much does something like that cost,
like a pyramid would probably be a key
of coke,
you know,
like I don't know,
back then what?
That's big money like a back then and
eight ball was 3:50.
Three and a half grams.
Okay.
Well look,
just give me a guesstimate.
Let's say 5,000
bucks.
10,000.
Well you think about the amount of money
to some people spend on parties just for
like catering and shit.
Yeah,
right.
Having a band play and fucking ice
sculpture,
why not have a big giant brick of coke?
Yeah,
absolutely.
And it looked pretty impressive when you
come in and go,
well that's an actual pyramid of coke,
but if you got busted,
if the cops came,
they probably busted for distribution.
That's prison there.
That's a key.
Uh,
below you can't go.
We're having a party.
What kind of party it was.
Smith Barney.
Yeah.
It's such a Walsh party,
bitch,
get out of here.
I went over and I just kind of scooped a
pile off of it and oh my God.
It's like,
you know,
you can't tell.
You're not lucky as this looks good
here.
There's.
And I blasted it up and I swear to God
about it a minute later I was like,
oh,
my arm was totally numb.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
And have problems,
you know.
So do you think that it was cut with
anything was it was just clean,
super cold,
you know,
like real cup,
you're not used to doing some super good
coke.
And,
and I go up to the guy got hit and he
got to call an ambulance and he's gone
and he's like,
no way man.
That'll attract heat.
You gotta ride it out,
dude,
that's the same thing,
man was talking about the 18 minutes
Chinese write it out,
you know,
and you're like,
dude,
I eat too much.
What?
He ate too much Chinese food once,
just like tons and like I guess from the
salt,
tons of salience that's a week talking
about doing and almost dying and he's
like,
ah,
too much hateful young.
I almost died.
Totally.
Same thing like if you eat shitloads of
like salt in your body or too much like
I've had too much sugar in my fucking
foot starts tingling that ever happened
to you?
How do you guys know what is causing the
ice cream Sundae?
Gummy bears will eat like bags of K.
I go,
hey dude,
that was too much.
Your body is held together with those
gummy bears.
Gummy bears are the glue to keep your
organs functioning.
That's the connections between the
neurons and the tissue.
That's limit and they told them,
don't stop partying because you will
die.
I really tell them that they own that
Mami documentary.
They're like a,
well,
your body's immune to it now.
It probably go in shock if you didn't
have it.
Whoa,
that's pretty well.
You drink that much with drinks and a
does a little powders I believe is
living.
I don't know.
He's like 70 or something.
Can you look that up?
Let me.
He was sick last year.
Pretty bad man.
From what?
Uh,
I guess just part of like running your
body.
I'll forever.
That's not what it looks like now
though.
Say Sixty nine.
Let's find a recent image of lemmy a
like,
right.
I would say right there.
The hat one with the glasses right
there.
That's him there.
That one right there?
Yeah,
there you go.
The last one.
We the warts on his face.
Did you get those removed?
Because he's letting me.
Doesn't give a fuck.
He's great.
He'll fuck him.
Even with these giant gross things
growing out of love.
That guy like a watch the documentary
mandates.
See there he is.
There he is with his collection.
He's gotten all those war swords and
stuff in his house.
Where does he live?
He lives by the rainbow in the same
apartment he's had for like 30 years.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow,
what a mad man.
I have it right.
Just rocker and he's still just hits the
road and just put a new record coming
out.
Does he have any kids?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
He was.
He had two children.
He was Hendrix.
Roadie Jesus Christ.
Isn't that crazy?
What a maniac.
Played in a band called a hawk when in
the 60 days has lost a lot of weight.
Metal injection and click on that.
Yeah.
Scare.
What was his health scare?
He got sick.
Something was wrong,
man.
That's the picture right there.
So now he's skinny as fuck.
There's that guy in the left.
Who?
Chris Jericho?
Yeah,
he's a wrestler.
Yeah.
I'll dare you.
The singer in a band there is man
playmates.
Great.
Sixty nine years old.
Still parties hard.
Yeah.
Animal.
How much do you think?
Yes.
Even at 69 tons.
Rambo,
pussy,
Brian.
It's the same girls.
Same Porn.
Girls are at the rainbow that are at the
on is a periscope.
How dare you sold him like that
while on the podcast.
I was at this girl's house the other day
and some 65 year old guys sitting on the
couch and I'm like,
why is that guy?
I'm leaving,
what is this place?
Went over her house and it was a guy
just sitting on the couch.
She's invited me back to her house with
this girl.
I'm hanging out with these two girls
periscoping and then I'm like,
wait a second.
There's a 65 year old man creepily
watching me and this was the guy.
Who was he?
I don't know.
He's just some doctor to this.
When does it play with the two girls?
One threw up on you.
Hold on.
Wait a minute,
hold on.
Jesus Christ.
Doctor wanted you to play with these
guys.
I just wanted to watch us play together
like all three.
If was just hanging out for you and the
two girls and the.
The guy was just like whacking off in
the corner.
He wasn't wearing off.
You're just hanging out just doing this
weird seed.
You talk to him at all?
I tried to but he was weird so I was
just like,
whatever.
I'll just.
These two girls are drunk right here,
so I'll just hang out with them and so
we're periscoping his house.
I,
I'm starting to think it was jim
mentioned,
if you get to that point where you.
You're so desperado is a sugar daddy
that you tell girls,
look,
I don't even care if you bring guys.
Yeah,
I think when you live here,
I think will bring guys back.
You do whatever you want.
Just let me know.
Just send me a jerk off in your mouth.
Every couple of days I ran out.
That is awesome.
I mean I was pretty sick.
What they have to do to get by in this
world,
man,
people have to fucking survive.
He living on the streets in Bangladesh.
Alright,
you gotta walk barefoot and carry a
basket on your head.
If you're a 65 year old dude and you got
a house in the Hollywood hills and you
want to get laid,
you're not famous.
What do you do?
You're not lemmy from motorhead,
bitch.
You got to let these girls live in your
house and bring home dudes like,
well,
we can't stay.
We need to bring home guys,
bring them here.
Pregnant.
Just don't disturb me when I'm beating
off.
That's basically the,
the whole recipe of the playboy mansion.
A lot of ways.
Yeah.
Well there was a house that I looked at.
There was one point in time where I was
thinking I should probably live in the
Hollywood hills,
be easier to get to the store and I get
home quicker,
get more work done and be like I could
live anywhere.
I thought about it for a very short
period of time,
like maybe a couple of weeks.
And I looked at this one house and the
House that I looked at was a really
cool.
And this guy had this glass back window,
like his entire back of his house was
glass and he was a guy that invented
bell bottoms.
Allegedly.
This was a story behind this guy.
And uh,
they used to call them wild man.
This case to show up at it is when Eddie
Bravo was a DJ script strip club and uh,
Eddie used to work at the Strip club and
this guy was rich as fuck.
And he would come in and he would pay a
shit load of money to get these girls
come back to his place.
He would go to strip clubs all
throughout the valley,
go everywhere wanted you,
had like a whole place that he would go
during the day and he would get these
girls.
And the story was that this guy was a
straight laced guy who smoked a lot of
cigarettes and he went
to the doctor and the doctor said,
listen man,
you're going to die.
You got to stop smoking.
Cigarettes are going to die.
Look,
if you need to smoke,
smoke weed.
I smoke pot.
It's not.
It doesn't give you cancer.
So this guy starts smoking pot joints
all day long.
Just changes his life.
Decides,
you know what man,
I don't want to work anymore.
I have money.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm going to just play guitar and I'm
going to get hookers.
So this guy decided to do just play
guitar and get hookers,
but apparently he was really mean to
them.
Which is sort of the opposite of what
you expect from potheads,
right?
That's filed bottom.
Expect gentle and apparently he used to,
he used to call it like bootcamping them
bootcamp.
These girls who treat them like shit,
who pay him a lot of money,
do you treat them like shit.
And he got off on the fact that he was
as gross old guy and he would get these
hot young girls and you would do mean
stuff to,
oh well this guy was selling his house.
So I went to look at the house and I
remember looking around and I was
thinking,
well this house is really expensive and
it's right there on the street.
And then I remember thinking like,
this guy has been bringing these hookers
back to this place.
So it was like a lot of people are
probably going to think that this guy is
an asshole and then going to rob them or
something.
Like,
what if I buy it?
And they go looking for wild man.
I'm like,
Yo,
I live here now.
Fucking two weeks after I thought that
he was killed in that house.
He brought a girl home and a.
apparently the girl brought guys with
her and they fucking shot him in the
neck style,
shot him in the neck and he bled out
right in the front where I was walking
around looking around.
Why when I was looking around his house,
go on,
this fucking guy could get shot and this
place.
It was funny because I brought that up
and the guy was selling the house,
the real estate guy.
He goes,
don't worry,
there's a state of the art security
system.
Cameras everywhere.
And I go,
you know what?
Those cameras are going to show.
They're going to show a due to ski mass
shootings and good luck.
That trial.
What the fuck are you talking about?
When I say that to the guy,
the guy was like,
you know,
the salesmen like,
you try to sell motorcycles just both
trying to sell this fucking bad as
Hollywood hills house.
Um,
but I bet they just fucking sucked that
blood out with a vacuum.
We cleaned it up nice.
It's sold that bitch within a week.
Those houses,
they go like,
I got up there.
That's Don Simpson's shit.
You ever read that book?
High Concept?
It was the producer that did all the
blockbusters.
He invented the blockbuster,
like uh,
right after jaws.
So a top gun.
What's the race one with Tom's offender?
Days of thunder.
He was a lunatic.
He gets street walkers,
bring them up to his mansion that had a
fucking,
like a 20 foot fence all the way around
and they'd be like,
you're going to eat poo and shit.
He just whipped coke and fucking went
nuts.
High Concept.
Read the book.
It's awesome.
Hilarious.
But a guy on coke say you're going to
eat poop.
That language,
like five-year-olds.
That book is crazy.
Hollywood weird us back then.
That's so fucked.
That thing that men want to women to get
through,
do degrading shit at.
So the way this is coming from the host
of fear factor,
I say with a grain of salt,
but the idea that someone would,
that that's what they get off on to get
off on taking someone who desperately
needs the money,
bringing them to their own house where
they live and sleep like you're.
You're haunting that place with these
memories of Demons bootcamping these
campaign.
That's what he used to call it.
That was his,
his expression fucking.
He smoked a lot of cigarettes during his
life.
So he had that raspy cigarette voice.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah,
boot camp.
Um,
I remember when I met the guy felt
really creeped out by them.
Like I wouldn't want to buy a house from
an asshole.
No,
just that alone.
I wouldn't want just not interested in
buying some assholes house.
Now as I think you're the asshole vibe
with spirit.
It would stay in the house,
man.
That's some creepy shit in the Hollywood
hills that has gone down over the last
hundred years.
And it's just kinda like those ghost up
there
know that the guy was an asshole.
That'd be one thing.
And you took it over and you're like,
oh,
I'll turn it into my house.
I have a nice party with my friends
over.
This is my house now.
Hay House.
I'm just let you know.
No more boot camping.
You're going to be nice to have
barbecues and hug.
We'll fucking swim together.
Everyone's going to be nice here.
Nope.
Bootcamp.
Just,
you know,
if you know that it was an asshole
house,
it's tough to do.
It's tough to buy.
You have other choices,
you know,
want to buy someone's.
It's kind of like joey is this bathroom,
you know,
that's the most haunted.
It's fucked up place in the road.
Imagine living in his place.
I would bug Joey Diaz.
His house in a heartbeat.
Ideas had a house and it was for sale.
I'll probably buy it just to make sure
nobody else had it.
Yeah.
My buddies,
my buddies moved into Jerry Diaz is a
apartment building over there.
No horseplay is crazy.
Crazy.
Right?
But was during the day
when Ralphie lived across the hall from
Doug Stan.
Hope who lived right down the street
from Joey and Joey was staying with
Gavin.
Oh my God.
It's chaos.
That was a crazy comedy.
Like squat house
at the.
They're in there now.
Luke is the bartender at the store and
then my other buddy,
Steve Henry,
he moved in.
So it's like comedy.
It's across the street from the game,
right?
Yeah.
How much does it cost to even rent up?
Nine slash 50.
It's good for the size.
For one bedroom.
It's like a massive studio was separate
kitchen everything,
but you got to a garage and stay for
Hollywood.
That's pretty God damn good.
If one of those places would be a good
idea to do a podcast audio to you're so
right now,
like think about like how much you have
to pay at the ice house.
You could get like an actual studio
apartment.
Totally.
Where's your studio?
My studio is in a studio.
Me and a couple of comics.
We're actually thinking about a.
they're building condos across the
street.
They're tearing down that
house of Blues.
Just all chipped and yeah,
that's going down.
Take three more months.
It's closed three more months and so
they're building condos are sent.
Me and a few comics were like,
we should just rent a all chip in like
$300 a month or whatever and rent a
place.
We could always just crash there if we
went to.
Yeah.
Instead of over those losers,
gonna wind up living their true.
Getting high on drugs camp.
Oh my God,
did I never going to forget that you'll
never forget it.
My friend Larry,
who,
uh,
used to live in the Hollywood hills had
the most amazing view I've ever seen in
my life up there.
To this day I've seen some dope views of
nature,
like nature views are my favorite views,
but nature of use don't work at night.
At night you just see dark mountains.
But Larry had a place at the top of
heaney and the view was like blade
runner.
It was like,
it didn't seem real.
It would look out.
You're like,
I didn't know anybody got to see this.
Like the view of all those lights from a
certain height,
like you don't want to be too high up,
you know,
you see it from an airplane.
Looks Pretty Dope,
but there's something about being at the
top of that dough.
Haney area.
Will you get this grid effect with this
amazing light show at night?
We would just go,
we would go out to his place.
I would bring people by his house just
to look at the view at night and when he
just got to see this,
especially in a clear night,
like after it rained.
Oh my God,
it was amazing.
Pauly shore's how would fuck you up?
His same thing.
He's got the.
He's right at the top.
I runyon three 63 slash 60.
You got,
you got a century city,
you got the grove.
Then over here you have downtown.
Then behind him he has all the hills
like running and everything,
you know,
and it's just with this light spill off
infinity.
Okay.
Pool.
And that would be one of those houses
though where you wonder about the
bootcamp in this house might be haunted.
You have to bring in some vegans to have
a fucking Vegan.
Seance.
Yeah.
You'd have to have some sort of a Yogi
and an infinity pool.
That's a hooker bath.
Drains.
Just pubic hair and condos.
And it was an amazing.
Patty said he bought it from the MTV
money in the eighties and he still owns
it.
Just rents it out and it's a good move.
Yep.
Real estate in the Hollywood hills is a
great investment at smart.
Well,
Paul has been smart with his money.
Like that really smart move.
He owns a place above.
Well,
he sold it to Scott,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
right.
The one right behind it.
The house know that's,
that's a great spot to crave.
Someone had that spot,
the place.
It's right at the top of that Little
Hill.
Dangerous.
He asked me to run it for a while.
He's on that house.
He's like,
you will live and pick the good room and
then pick like four guys that you want
to live with it.
You can.
Uh,
you know,
it's a great idea.
Comedy House.
Like they used to have an crest hill
total.
Yeah,
exactly.
But my only worry was like the comics
moving every couple of
months ago can't make rent and then I'll
send you this landlord instead of just a
room.
A.
It sounds like work.
Yeah.
You got to collect money.
Chase people down whenever you're
dealing with broke dudes.
It's always a man,
which is exactly what you would deal
with it.
You got it.
You would wind up having your name on
the condo because the older guy,
the ability,
we'll just,
we'll pay you and then you a man.
You could just sell my part out.
Someone else like what the fuck?
Nobody wants it.
And then how about this?
You got rent.
Why are you being a Dick?
Man,
that's the best.
The best.
Come on man.
You got money.
You owe money.
Not what's going on here.
Don't get mad at me.
You fuck.
It's crazy,
man.
That's the worst.
The worst is when broke.
People that owe money.
Turn it around and get upset at you.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
How about,
how about what?
You know,
dude,
where were living here?
Yeah.
Now I have to pay your apart and people
just always look for some sort of an
excuse to not have to contribute.
It's just.
And when you're dealing with starving,
struggling artist,
it's the same sort of mentality that
makes people flick cigarettes out the
window.
It's not thinking about anybody but
themselves.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
It's a cigarette thing too,
man.
There's something about poison your body
with cigarettes.
I've always wondered,
like I was hanging out with the tally of
the day.
I didn't bring it up because I love
them,
but smoke cigarette dropped on the
ground,
stepped on it,
left it there,
and I was like,
dude,
you know,
that's littering.
Like,
what'd you do that with a rapper?
Would you do that with like a,
a glamorized growing up,
you know,
with James,
Deane stepping on the cigarette or
flicking it.
It used to always be like a thing that
you mean cops would,
do you know it,
it never was.
It never was considered a lender.
They sent me to the end like and then we
went to boot camp.
Oh you want five grand?
The house and put on the gloves.
Favorite is as they're driving this
prius.
Oh,
I'm saving the environment.
They flick a cigarette out of their
fucking Prius.
Dude.
I've had a running tally on this show
about people in praises that I've seen
throw cigarettes out the window.
It's up to eight people in a prius throw
cigarette out the window.
It's like,
don't tell me you're driving that Prius
for the environment or some money.
They're cheap.
You can try one of those things.
Uh,
Daniel Cormier,
the UFC light heavyweight champ.
He has won and he said it costs like 30
bucks to fill up and it lasts a month.
Yeah.
I went to,
I went to San Fran with another comic
and it,
we put like $26 and we were there.
I was like,
are you kidding?
Like my motorcycle.
I stopped three times.
They're great on gas,
but their dog shit cars just killed it
for me.
Man.
I've been in so many Prius's lately that
every uber driver has.
One is the track home of cars.
That's what it is.
It's a track home.
They all look the.
You just go
in and go,
where's mine?
Do you ever leave the arclight and you
go look at the fucking Prius is in here.
Yeah.
That's all it is,
is everybody had one of those.
It wouldn't be so dangerous.
The problem is other people have fucking
trucks,
semis and shit.
And you have a prius.
Prius get hit by a semi.
After I got rear ended,
man,
I started really reconsidering the type
of automobile I drive.
The Porsche took the hit pretty good
because it's designed German engineering
and as a crash beam in the back that
absorbs the impact,
but I didn't get hit that hard either.
You know,
you,
you think about all these fucking idiots
out there.
Like I told you about van Owen Street,
these caved in cars from assholes that
are just texting or sleeping or whatever
the fuck they're doing.
That's the problem with driving as the
other people.
You're dealing with so many variables.
It's none of them have insurance either.
Half these people on our roads don't
even have licenses and insurance,
whatever.
It's brutal out there,
man.
I'm on a motorcycle and I just couldn't
laugh like you.
I'll look right at a guy,
Joe.
I'm riding.
That guy will look at me.
He'll look like this.
He sees me put his blinker on.
It just starts coming over.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Who knows you're going to move.
So I started talking like,
Hey man,
I'm right here.
Hey,
and then now we won't look like,
Oh,
I don't hear you.
I'm coming over here.
I need this lane,
and they just,
if they know that they can believe
that's it,
they can push you up.
Do you see that video of the guy on the
BMW and there's a guy on a motorcycle
that has a Gopro on his helmet.
That's unbelievable.
I get off the fucking phone.
Stay off the phone.
You're driving.
So then the guy runs them off the road.
Yeah,
he hits him on purpose.
There's a video of the kid like looking
to his left leg and his left foot.
Boom.
He gets hit
and you just hear and go,
oh,
oh fuck.
This guy picks him up.
He's like nine slash 11.
I've been here.
You know,
it's,
I should find whoever has that fucking
BMW beat the fucking shit out of him.
I can't believe that detail man.
What cons?
What a piece of shit that's a human on a
vehicle easily could have been
paralyzed.
He easily could have said easily could
have been run over in the other
direction.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
he loses his job.
He's got broke legs now and he loses his
house and everything for this fucking
Dick that's like,
I gotta get to my job.
Fuck you.
It wasn't what he was doing it on
purpose.
He did it perfect because that guy told
him,
get off your phone.
Yeah.
He first,
he honks at him.
He goes,
Hey,
get off your phone.
And then he pulls up and then the guy
like,
oh,
it turns eight bucks.
Then he starts riding and left.
It looks like he's like Santa,
Santa Monica.
What?
Berea there.
And then boom,
the car hits him.
Yeah,
most likely the kid did not have as A.
Oh,
here it is.
We'll,
we'll end.
This doesn't have the fucking plate now.
So he really doesn't know how to be a
traffic camera or something.
Well,
one would hope so.
But uh,
traffic cameras probably most likely not
going to get the.
This isn't like serious.
What's
on the brand there by Alan?
Nate's says kid keeps looking back
because apparently he's like right on
birthday,
right in front of coin.
Jesus Christ man.
So just cut them off.
He just got in front of them.
Wow,
this guy helps him up.
You shouldn't help a guy out when he
announced it like that.
I know he might be fucked up.
I was furious when I saw visit visit my
crowd funding site.
That wasn't the car pulled over.
The car took off,
took off.
It was a black beemer.
No,
it wasn't black right here,
is it?
No,
it was before that.
It was,
um,
you could see it before it.
You could see the color before it.
Before it,
right at the beginning.
Jamie?
Yes.
It's a beamer on the left Femur,
but it looks like it's look like kind of
a gray.
I can't believe that guy did that.
Anybody knows who did a fucking find
employees.
That guy needs to be in jail.
Can't move.
Before you go,
you got to hear this story.
Joe Gilby Clarke from guns and roses.
He was hit on his motorcycle on Ventura
Boulevard about five years ago.
Got Hits and runs them two years after
that.
Gilby hospital for the first six months.
Can't walk plates in his legs.
A cane got hit him and ran.
The guys had a party two years later.
He's telling the dude,
yeah man,
Hey,
that guy a couple of years ago on a
motorcycle.
I just kept going,
man,
he's kind of drunk.
I think.
He goes,
really?
yeah,
over on Ventura Boulevard,
man.
These bikers.
Fuck them,
man.
I mean,
you know,
he,
I don't know.
I hit him.
I don't know what happened.
The guy knew gilby called them.
I guess I got the guy.
He's at this party.
Two years later they sent the police
over.
It was the dude.
He told the story at a party,
so this guy is not going to be able to.
First of all,
he has some damage on his car.
He hit the bike most likely.
So he's got something on the side of his
class.
He just bumped the wheel.
Yeah,
maybe.
Yeah.
You might have bumped the wheel yet from
behind.
He's going to tell someone because
that's going to weigh on him.
I hope so.
May Too.
What a cunt.
That's such a scary thing that someone
could do that to a person.
Just hit them with a car is fucking
brutal,
dude.
You know he was texting.
He didn't realize he did it.
No,
he didn't.
He drove on that guy's ass and hit all
the guy.
Kept looking like he's coming up on him.
You see his head,
he's gone.
What,
what the fuck?
You know?
Well two things.
One,
don't start shit with someone that's
just on their phone.
Yeah,
he can't do it.
He shouldn't have done that in the first
place.
Not excusing the grind for hitting him
in the car,
but you know,
you never know what you're catching
someone you can.
You might be catching someone at the
fucking verge of a nervous breakdown.
Their wife just broke up with him that
she cleaned out the bank.
The fucking.
They got fired at work.
Their dog got poisoned by the neighbor
or the [inaudible].
Who knows?
And you just,
you know,
fuck you.
Get off your phone.
What the fuck did you know?
You're catching someone at nine touch
the button.
Exactly.
Don't do it.
Be Nice.
Flux.
And this city is also filled with
gangsters.
I mean,
let's be half these people are on your
mind.
Probably murdered.
People add their packing.
Well,
how many people out there just so angry
and frustrated too?
Yeah,
I didn't get that role.
Fuck him.
Just everything.
I mean there's 20 million people.
You're dealing with way too many human
beings.
You're dealing with all sorts of fucking
economic problems and who knows what
else and relationship shit.
There's an episode of Radiolab that I'm
listening to right now where it talks
about people that were going to kill
somebody that almost we're going to kill
somebody now.
How prevalent it is.
This woman was talking about this ex
boyfriend that she had that was
blackmailing her and said,
you can't,
if you have another boyfriend,
I'm going to fucking tell them and I'm
going to send them sex tapes that we
made together and was saying that I want
to haunt you for the rest of your life.
So she invited the guy over her house
and she was cooking dinner for him and
she was going to stab him.
Whoa.
And she had the knife in her hand.
The Guy ran away and they asked her
like,
how close were you stabbing him?
She was like 60 percent,
60 percent established.
She was thinking,
if this guy wasn't in my life,
I could be happy,
and so she was just going to stab him
like she was so maniacal about.
And you've got to think how many people
get that close.
Yeah,
but this is a normal person who got that
close.
They got that close.
That's crazy because then the,
the next five minutes,
your whole life changes and you go to
prison.
You know,
I would give her a free pass.
I'd give her a pass.
You guys a con?
He's trying to fucking say she could
never have a boyfriend again.
He's going to send the out.
That ruining her life.
Apparently he was according to her
vicious asshole.
If you're a woman,
man,
this the shit that you have to deal
with.
It's not that much different than a lot
of ways that,
that kind of bullying,
that kind of physical,
frightening shit.
It's a lot like someone in a car hitting
someone on a bike.
It's like you can get away with it,
you know you can get away with it.
So you do.
What are you thinking?
That moment,
at least you can get away with it.
That's the con deist aspect of people
victimizing other people when they can
get away with it.
Like that black male is the garbage of
America,
which didn't have any violence in like
that.
Especially in relationship violence.
It's a scary shit,
man.
That's what cops always say.
It's the scariest thing for them when
they show up.
Domestic violence.
Yeah.
Wait,
what'd you say about black guys?
They sound what?
He said,
man.
Black male,
bro.
No,
black man.
Eric,
a black band.
Brian was Brian Band on Ferguson.
Bride Red Band on Baltimore detail,
right?
We've got to get out of here that we ran
out of time.
That was three hours for real.
Thank you so much for today and
folks check out his podcast.
If you are into the psaltery sounds of
Dean del Ray Singh in Let.
How do you do that Shit with you?
Yeah,
there it is.
Let's it be.
Talk on itunes.
Also check out his podcast with Tom rare
because it's fucking awesome.
Toronto next month,
man.
Dean del Rey.
Where you guys at?
Did the 18th.
We're doing the cinema and it's going to
be a theater show and it's a live
podcast and both of us are going to do a
full comedy show
and where can they find out about that?
Got a desk squat dot TV.
Click on tour dates.
Alright,
you fuckers.
We'll see you next week.
Until then,
much love and big kisses.